les nuls bonsoir martin veyron bonsoir
margoline bonsoir quand j'ai lu bovy
j'ai vu vous étiez tous les trois pieds
noirs non les garçons cadets garçons
pieds noirs qui est auvergnate où l'on
fasse si on veut et pourquoi vous avez
perdu l'accent fais nous un petit clan
comme ça là bas on n'est pas typé du
tout vous donne un peu dur à toi un peu
quand même un petit peu mieux on a donné
aux citoyens
igt toi merci commence à ce point de vue
les super stars dont l'accès d'un ghana
limite ça fout la trouille
alors comment ça se passe avec lescure
innocent sur certains trucs c'est moi
m'a dit là l'histoire du chien l'a quand
même oui alors c'est quoi c'était quoi
l'on me raccompagnant son côté on avait
envie pour démarrer les émissions de
bahts faire un petit clin d'oeil si
j'ose dire aux otages oui bon on était
allé tourner un jour dans une spa et on
avait vu des chiens comme ça a senti les
vacances tous derrière des barreaux et
tout et on s'est dit on les pauvres sont
emprisonnés eux aussi voilà j'en avais
envie de faire de 205 m jours de
détention qui ce que j ai et on était
vachement fier de cette idée et un soir
au restaurant soit avec lescure
effectivement on lui en parle
au départ ils étaient un peu
enthousiaste en disant ouais c'est vrai
que c'est drôle et lendemain après une
nuit de réflexion qui nous a convoqués
en a parlé tous ensemble ça peut être
une censure nous avez vous pensez
vraiment que c'est drôle au club pour la
première c'était la première
ouais moyens au cc pour cette menace
faire des trucs pas mal parce qu'on
vient de voir sa part le monde parle de
ça une discussion panis ans fils et basf
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé là c'est
la société basf qui les bogdanoff allen
c'est un jeu presque celle initiale je
connais bien les regards très jolis
traits qui eux ont vu des photos dans le
monde je restais dans l'actuelle aussi
donc il y avait la tronche de kurt weill
times le truc c'était donc il pleurait
sur des chants racistes et bss l'émotion
intacte
ils ont juste ce cette image est là la
pub de son prêt donc ils ont bloqué
jusqu'au cou avec un référé pour babel
la guerre il était c'est pas un autre
professeur d'anglais
ah ouais d'accord ouais ils sont quand
même assez mouillé dans les larmes
ils ont déjà beaucoup alors le 7 d'or
ils vous ont augmenté chez canal+ parce
qu'ils sont plein de thunes chez canal
frustré les augmenter avancé avant cet
échange écrivait il saison prince se
renseigner et vous avez des propositions
de bouygues a alors commencé à se
presser raconter certaines des
propositions nous a demandé si on
voulait aller
sur youtube c'est vrai que
on est bien à canal quoi on a des
interlocuteurs malade on l'a déjà
exsangue était simplement se sont
honnêtement est-ce que ce qui passe à
l'heure actuelle sur notre chan sur
canal ça pourrait passer à une heure de
grande écoute sur la i ne sais pas si ça
vaut 45 citoyen pas évident ça change
pilot dans le sens de la roue de la
fortune que dans le champ au sens de
tennis glande il faut bien le dire c'est
pas de marseille a cru remarquer jean
marc marquez s'est pas très drôle mais
c'est bien bon alors on va tous les
prendre un par an là puisque vous faites
un journal télévisé nullement gildas je
demanderai pas ce que vous en pensez
parce que j'imagine que c'est votre pote
gildas alors poivre d'arvor
alors là je t'ai mis à bord à lui c'est
le pire je l'avais personnes ouais je
suis physiquement à lui c'est le pire il
fait d'abord savoir pourquoi ses chances
d'accès épidermique mais pourquoi harper
d un bouton à bord
oui oui alors qu'il est pourquoi il est
pas plus mal canopy moins chaud bon
niveau après bon rosie jeu j'aime bien
le nose il est sincère serions-nous est
un rigolo un petit peu je sais même pas
qui c'est au fil des ans une relation
consentie et enchanté jeu disons que
cuba da tu paies sur mon prise à dakar
guillaume durand avec jérôme dupont très
bien qui a en effet expliqué sur l'a5 le
dimanche rsa français tous âges pour ça
c'est bien d'accord jean claude bourret
milliards il ya avant prédestiné mais
bon alors tu as bien mais ça lui va bien
avec ses côtés de jean pierre pernaut
ex-aequo à j'ai pas pensé à changer
là-bas bruno masure j'aime bien
alors avec toulouse donc tout ce que
vous dites que vous avez bien c'est que
vous feriez bien le jt n avait que oui
c'est ça joseph poli sans faute d'accord
henri sannier a jamais vu passer à 9,6
en plein champ sur trois séries télé
bretagne et cécile ajoute m
on n'a jamais vous j'ai jamais vu en jt
oui vos concurrents patrick sébastien
samedi à moi je trouve que sébastian la
démolit injustement et ça je veux le
dire parce que son émission mur assure
le maire non il se déclare non il se
décarcasse ce mec faut pas déconner faut
regarder ce qui fait qu'en vingt je
gagne a toujours des idées qu'on aime
qu'on aime pas bon ce qu'on lui reproche
un peu c'est d'être un peu trop gentil
avec tout le monde c'est vrai qu'il aime
trop tout le monde mais quand même ya
tout le temps des retrouvailles des
familles de pionniers
ça c'est alors maintenant collaro on est
là parce que vous êtes bien là c'est un
problème de colonne ont alors quitté il
ya d'autres programmes de l'a5 si l'on
comparé sur l'a6 alors vous n'est pas au
programme de nuit le roucas avant que je
peux dire c'est pas non à bankass nice
et pas qu'à ça c'est moins bien que les
nullités qui s'est passé ça nous fait
pas rire bon ça fait pareil à grand bois
entre musiciens
enfin les inconnues sont comme vous sont
quatre et bien sûr simple a jamais vus
sur scène on n'a pas vu leur paye alors
les imitateurs blanc andré lamy 1810
date cette limite que les morts il imite
le lui rend à imiter les morts
clairement c'est un mec il pourrait se
mettre
mais qui est capable d'imiter coluche
tout ça il se met sur un drap avec
quatre bougies autour sur un drap noir
et soit parfait alors eric blanc c'est
ça ces deux matchs ou sinon rien moi
j'ai jamais un rôle à donner à bord du
très honnêtement leur égard
non il est formé à la télévision ça
arrive pas souvent quand on fait du
skate quand on prend comme ça d une
équipe où il est bien ici même en vidéo
il fait bien mitterrand et devient
giscard il fait bien mais il manquait
bien c'est qu'on arrive à oublier dans
ses imitations qu'il est noir
ouais ouais ouais il est noir c'est le
noir qui aimait les blagues de ses
journaux alors est ce que vous
connaissez martin veyron intérêt à dire
oui
vraiment d'accord l'amour propre ne le
reste jamais très longtemps mais un
martin martin panou de ton livre mon
dernier livre tant dernier livre bien il
sort quelques années après de l'amour
propre ouais et après que ces gens qui
sont un petit peu énervé russe dans
l'amour propre jeu ça donne ça allait
mal élevés ils se marieront jamais faite
pour les hommes qui prévient pour élever
l'enfant et ça dit quoi par exemple du
mois le truc le plus drôle du livre boom
a rendu tout d'abord c'est très sérieux
c'est fait pour élever les chiens viasat
a eu le plaisir maintenant tu paies et
autant que ce soit bien fait tara
combien de chiens mais moi je dis oui il
ya une petite fille sera séchée film en
exergue
alors c'est une fois ce qui dit les
enfants c'est comme l'épée on ne
supporte que nessia c'est bien c'est pas
génial et c'est d'elizabeth chai qui
vise à battre ferrer c'est pas une
copine heideger david ferrer c'est une
c'est une philosophe c'est ma tante en
plus avant mais mais la raison aux
remarques de l'insee qui m'a tout type
soit je le connais pas va te dis ouais
il se trouve que laval
ouais qu'est ce qu'il raconte moi c'est
beau qu'est ce qu'il raconte mais des
way en bd c'est des histoires assez à
ces personnels assermentés de mon
matériel philosophique c'est un peu à
part c'est il ya trois ans il ya le
directeur artistique de vanille tic
magazine italien haut vol qui s'est dit
tiens on fait toujours faire la mode par
les photographes pourquoi on demanderait
pas à les dessinateurs de bd parce que
mon la bd donc et bien et il a donc
demandé à ma tatie à l'autre rogers
d'illustrer le travail des designers et
ça a très bien marché
les stylistes était content parce qu'on
vendait bien leurs modèles
la revue du coup a bien marché
et le résultat c'est ce niveau là ah
c'est ça c'est un truc assez mattotti
pour magnifier ouais d'accord c'est tout
ce qu'il a fait pour illustrer la valeur
très bien vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter les enfants n'ont aussi bien sur
la scène qu'elle raconte alors sur la
saq on m'a jamais rien interdit
justement chez c'est extraordinaire
d'ailleurs on me laisse faire tout ce
que je veux et si c'est pas terrible ce
n'est pas de leur faute à des trucs un
peu salée ouais ouais ça arrive donc il
ya pas deux est ce que la fille du
générique elle plonge tout à chaque
émission
alors on va commencer par un mini débat
en forme d'interview parallèle c'est à
dire bien chiant je vais vous poser à
tous les trois les mêmes questions à
tour de rôle des questions qu'on vous a
déjà pesé à peu près 200 mille fois donc
accrochez vous pourquoi les nuls
terrible parce qu'on est parti
d'objectifs nul à une parodie
d'objectifs nul et puis dans les
couloirs personne ne connaissait tron
connaissais simplement l'histoire
d'objectifs nul donc à canal tout le
monde disait oui sont les nuls etc
donc c'est resté naturellement gildas a
pris le pas ouais puis après on sait
démerdé pour garder le nom quoi ouais
donc on s'appelle les nuls encore
j'étais pas d'accord du je pouvais jouer
vous voulez quoi elle est super pour les
déchets l'eau mais c'était après il est
allé gueuler chez de greffe le directeur
je trouve les noms ça plus est nul ça
marchera pas comme non pas travailler
alors vous êtes vous êtes à un groupe
qui a été créée artificiellement par les
par les dirigeants de canal+ qui vous
est demandé de collaborer
alors ce qui nous incite concerne moi
personnellement c'est alain de greef et
elle est albert mathieu avec bruno
carette je travaillais sur la côte les
plans une émission d'humour donc nous
ont demandé de venir faire des maquettes
à paris et c'est là qu'on a rencontré
sézigue ça c'est très même pas ce départ
oui on sent cadrait pas trop et puis
il était avec une équipe et puis voilà
jour ça fuse un mariage forcé en quelque
sort au départ puis après non ah oui
c'est un match forcément j'étais avec
deux autres potes et qu'il me suis
engueulé puis après on s'est engueulé et
puis on continue à s'engueuler et j'ai
vu au flipper je suis demandé s'il avait
du boulot il m'a pris et ça a commencé à
fonctionner quand cette affaire
et ça a marché tout de suite puisqu'on
est dans la premier set d'heure après la
sortie de machin donc les gens je me
souvient mme amos a vu 3 3
je sais d'or c'est un peu pour corinne
et un peu du à succès le succès
l'ambition mais vous l'avez bien mérité
qu'est ce qui t'a gas le plus chez eux
ce qui t'énerve plus chez les deux là
comment ça on pas enfin rhodia effectuer
des hommes qui truquent privé pour tout
de suite ça prenne des proportions
énormes il va jouer avec ça pendant des
heures et des heures et des jours et des
jours paru alors ça ça va m'énerver ça
mais souvent collé un jour elle va dire
par exemple on suit pas c'est pas un
juif il me fait chier mais tout avait dû
corriger la traite d'antisémite
alors qu'il n'est pas du tout anticipé
et à la serpent à lunettes c'est à dire
qu'un jour il va se lever bien virulent
de mal viré aussi jamais commandement
mais à côté de ça je les aime bien tous
les deux ça fait sept ans qu'on
travaille ensemble est vraiment non
honnêtement je veux pas leur tirer ce
qui te gonfle chez eux s'ils échappent à
ce guidage gps est toujours à la bourre
total et chantal ans pour la tête
régulièrement sur des conneries genre
très con du style la feuille là je
l'avais laissée là tu l'a dépassé de 20
centimes et a même dû lancer des trucs
j'aime tout chez eux surtout leur art
et toi qu'est ce qu'ils gonflent le plus
c'est chantal par exemple général non je
chante qui chante elle est déchire les
captages pourquoi faire des seniors
espèce de réflexe d'une main c'est super
dur a fait on a essayé en plus alors ce
qui fait que tu peux pas laisser traîner
un contrat quand il ya un journal tu
sais quand elle l'a lu quoi c'est une
prouesse qui sont déchirés csam
l'exaspère mais on m'a expliqué sa mère
énormément tant les six ans ferme ce sa
mauvaise foi surtout très très mauvaise
un garçon de mauvaise foi mais pas du
tout
dis moi est ce que tu as déjà couché
avec un nul non non non non sincèrement
même pas soir de tout je suis pas un
sondage un peu ce qui est étonnant c'est
qu'on a jamais des fois je me demande
s'ils me prenne pour une bronze des fois
je me disais que si je regarde bon c'est
vrai que c'est toujours un billet en
pantalon j'essaie de m'habiller comme
j'arrive jamais avec les jupettes et
tout parce qu'on travaille au bureau on
est là comme ça ils arrivent avec leur
gîte moi aussi c'est vrai qu'on n'est
pas quand même des modèles d'élégance
donc on a vraiment des rapports moi je
considère un peu bon c'est vrai que je
valide et j'aurais passé sera incestueux
toi non plus pareil tu veux pas non plus
non bien sûr jamais eu envie je sais pas
j'aime le les subir nage un peu crevé
comme ça non non non bien sûr que non
non ne s'est jamais passé ce nom mais
dès que des canules s'arrête si tu as
fait tu me dire hey toi oui mais je sais
qu'il ya probablement plein de plein de
gens qui s'imaginent des choses et les
inconnus c'est ce qui contredit coin si
je pense
contre le noir et l'autre là le gros
point noir mis ya pas de gros shebab ont
toujours dit qu'elle est sans nulle
préféré j'ai pas nue préféré gmc des
groupes
je vais dire honnêtement c'est de [ __ ]
la merde financier net est vrai que nono
bruno c'était mon pote depuis depuis pas
mal de temps ça faisait 10 12 ans qu'on
se connaissait donc c'est vrai que
c'était on était on travaille ensemble
antibes on aimait à paris ensemble et
tout donc c'est vrai que c'était
quelqu'un de très proche mais c'est vrai
que on a eu des moments durs ensemble
des moments merveilleux ça ne vous a
vachement rapprocher je les aime tous
les deux
chabal lui doit de l'argent ce qu'on bon
alors c'est tant mieux et toi qu'est
attendu le préfet seconde cette remarque
ah bon au cap a en fait y'a pas
d'histoires entre vous quoi ya pas de
problème non c'est ça le drame
ces ballons on s'arrête on va demander à
françois rollin professeur rollin ce
prix resituer le débat s'il vous plaît
mon pauvre tirer quoi mon pauvre tirer
vraiment vous me faites pitié la
chercher des scandales et des bruits de
chiottes pour faire de l'audimat mais
mon pauvre ami mais qu'est ce que j'en
ai à secouer l'animal mais moi si les
gens s'intéressent pas ce que je fais
une occase ap allez-y sap et qu'est ce
que j'en ai à [ __ ] ma toute façon
c'est le service public ici c'est payé
d'avancé on n'a pas besoin d'eau d'in
avait déjà payé la redevance alors si
vous n'êtes pas contents ça paie l'arrêt
vous allez
sur tf1 il ya eu chaud à rien c'est ça
ma date
dion sur m6 ya un film sur canal il ya
des documentaires fabuleuse ap restait
pas là foutez nous la paix regardez
comme des idiots la halle et zapper il
ya trop de gens pour moi encore encore
aller bagoul barrez-vous bon il ya trop
de monde thierry reprenait l'émission
c'est le meilleur moyen de faire baisser
l'audit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
mister api see you in the lovely décor
des folies bergère oui je parle en
anglais c'est la langue qui comprend
depuis dix ans et puis que ces idées à
télévision américaine tient bien je vais
rester lingyu pickles du riz des
américains tivi y aura une équipe bis
moi bon chantal oui je me barre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai que tu que les idées à tout
va bien se lance alors à pas pour le
dire
dis moi tu es né à alger à oran à oran
oran donc vous en algérie tu as passé
son enfance à à pacy non j'ai passé mon
enfance à massifs silva grave quand tu
étais petit donc tu voulais être
aviateurs cessa pompiers exactement
parce que j'aime le feu c'est un truc
qui j'aime le feu et tué deux pompiers
et quand tu viens alors un jour donc tu
tues tu voulais dessiner une bd qui se
passait dans une radio et c'est comme ça
que tu es rentré à radio monte carlo
c'est comme ça que c'est au oui ça exact
mais moi je veux faire une bd avec un
lieu quoi c'était bien lieu n'est pas un
héros de sa radio andorre que tu es
rentré imbéciles à ces radios en or par
exemple
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas grave c'est qu'il avait zappé
du mont d'or j'ai zappé radium et puis
et puis un jour donc tu décides de faire
une bd qui se passait dans une radio
radio et tu rentres comme ça à radio
monte-carlo radio andorre du sud durant
deux ans avec artie parreira et c'est là
après à l'oreille en coin que tu as
rencontré pierre lescure non à l'oreille
en coin
j'ai rencontré franck adrian voilà qui
je faisais l'oreille en coin un essai
après à rmc où j'ai rencontré pierre
lescure bien les a fait le rayon quoi
toi
allez taper les trucs sur les politiques
et où j'ai fait un mois les aventures de
deux de deux mecs qui écouter la radio
pourquoi tu ne l'as jamais dis pas ce
que je suis et été passée donc après sur
canal tout à fait les infos j'ai fait le
la météo à la météo on était donc
monsieur météo de canal au début van
peel la suite on l a su temps la
conasysed redevenu tu as trois enfants
j'ai deux enfants j'ai deux filles
depuis deux petites filles c'est pas là
moi aussi tu en es content très content
on commence à rendre service à sa mère
la plus grande et la petite elle fait
chier tu as acheté une ferme dans le
lubéron dans en normandie en normandie
ok je vois tu veux pas mais dès la
gestion cdg veut pas mêler les tds que
je te dit une énorme et voilà bon va
passer la promo alors parce que je vois
que sur la vie personnelle tuant excuse
moi tu es d'accord alors le on a fait
une émission donc la semaine dernière
pour parler de la promo sur antenne 2
bons qu'à crois pas trop mais pas trop
mal d'argent
nous on s'en fout c'est france 2 ces 500
balles quand on dit antennes ne le
savent pas ça ici je savais voulait
donner tout de suite le pognon non je
ferai après avec moi quand j'irai donc
le 20 novembre sort chez albin michel
un livre qui s'appelle l'info c'est
rigolo oui elle ne dit pas le contraire
c'est un livre très très bien et coûtent
pas cher là pendant qu'on parle parle un
peu parce que pour l'instant il ya le
livre qui apparaît en gros sur l'écran
d'accord d'accord c'est formidable
formidable chez albin michel crépu
sédition même le prix vous fera rire 300
pages de bêtises pour 99 800 balles doit
cesser temps d'information dans un même
mode caché un livre entièrement original
non non c'est une compil amer nous on
n'a rien fait mais dans tout compiler et
albin michel a compilé alors à part ça
vous êtes tous les trois tous les matins
sur europe 1 2 donc entre 7h et 9h pas
mal pas loin et puis elle filme enfin
pas le film que vous devez écrire parce
que je suis là vous êtes pas on attend
que vous allez tout la fête on tourne
tourne normalement au printemps on le
monte l'été on mixe l'été il sort dans
l'antre septembre et décembre 93 30 93
notre réseau et il faut qu'il soit écrit
pour qu'on pour arriver à tenir vendredi
le 22 décembre un mérite d'être précis
que vous en êtes poche 3
aujourd'hui on a écrit bateau d'une très
belle écriture alors puis un autre film
en fait celui qui sort maintenant wild
soir sinon vous avez écrit l'adaptation
ouais c'est un très grand carton aux usa
c'est vrai même carton à françois
hollande dans c'est bien marché une
bonne première semaine avant le final et
c'est un film
marie c'est ton interview dimanche bon
bah c'est un rêve c'est un film
américain donc avec deux crétins qui
s'appelle dana carvey et qui est un
acteur formidable bijoux garde qui a les
cheveux longs il ya lunettes et mike
myers qui a écrit le film voilà ce qui
ressemble un peu à manoeuvre et si
longtemps il va me tuer parce qu'il
n'aime pas le film et voilà c'est pour
les crétins qui aiment leur droit qu'il
faut être très bien moi quand même entre
8 et 14 ans plus tard au dessus tu peux
te faire un peu chier j'ai tout compris
le dire j'étais assis à côté de faire
quatre y compris au film c'est facile
quoi c'est un peu pour les bas du front
mais c'est agréable on s'en sort sans
effet coiffe effet l'adaptation fait la
promo on l'a fait on a fait tout
l'adaptation c'est à dire qu'ils avaient
du mal à traduire certains gags
il y avait des fausses pubs des trucs
qui était vraiment très très américain
don qui nous ont appelés en nous disant
tenez regardez ce film et dites nous si
vous avez envie de bosser dessus nous
largue on est allés tous les deux ça me
fait marrer c'est en vo non sous-titrée
on a compris un peu répond à ta place
lui je ne crois pas et le moins chiante
mois il a raison mais ça arrive et dit
c'est toi qui me regarde tu me pose une
question autrement
ces deux heures personne nue derrière
cités s'étaient yeux
oh pardon ce film je vais rapporter
combien cette affaire ça nous a rapporté
une somme difficilement concevable pour
un esprit moins
ouais mais tu es très très bien fait
j'ai un pourcentage là dessus non plus
n'a pas pour ça c'est parce qu'on n'a
pas pris de pourcentage à peine mais
c'était même un peu gêné mais bon c'est
de l'ordre
c'est de l'ordre de beaucoup avant alors
tu es prêt on va passer aux questions
qu'on pas d'accord en effet c'est ok
d'accord t'es prêt là mais pour répéter
la question est ce que tu préfères
staline ou hitler
charest de prendre hitler parce que je
me serais plus con c'est tu dois partir
de 3 ans dans un vaisseau spatial
tpr est là mais tu préfères des
merveilles villars où patrick juvet
comprendre d'eux comme ça il s'occupe
il préférait faire l'amour avec une
fille très très très laide ou un mec
très très très beau oui je suis très
très très laide ah ben quand même à lui
les mecs s'était jamais arrivé en plus
acquis trouves-tu le plus de
circonstances atténuantes jacques pradel
[Rires]
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles des
petites de quel âge à peu près 12 13 ans
quoi 10 13 ans mais l'islande ou
voilà [ __ ] 20 jeunes qui tapent sur
une vieille dans la vie de la vieille a
déjà été fait
elle a eu déjà des joueurs tandis que la
jeune tu l'unique tout de suite à 12 ans
étaient ces questions cons mais non mais
c'est bien c'est bien a donc disons ça
disons l'avion le mot le plus con en
amour
merci encore oui oui merci merci merci
comme si tu penses à dire pendant dix
ans qu'est ce tu choisis pas de bouffe
ou pas de cul à un jeu tout de suite en
espagne deux pas d'un fait bouffer tout
droit du goût fait le cube c'est pour ça
que les idées
mais j'ai confié tu bouges pas beaucoup
alors qu'est ce tu prends pas de bouffée
pas de but ouais ouais bah discuter
sinon ouais d'accord tu préfères être
réincarné en bergers allemands un setter
irlandais ou épagneul breton web berger
allemand les jours à bout lourd plus
vraiment juif je suis berger allemand de
l'asie je lui mort des couilles la bombe
arrive dans 5 minutes tu fais quoi
je continue interview je suis un
professionnel
il sait des possibles est ce que tu
accepterais d'échangés toi d'échanger
une paralysie générale contre la faim de
la faim en somalie et au soudan et au
souhait au soudan elle est le mal il ya
le prêt à aller au mali allait tuer
paralysé jusqu'à la fin de tes jours
allongée sur un lit de légumes dégâts si
ces gens-là mangent à leur faim
d'accord pas encore pendant tout le
temps tout le temps hayat urbain des
impôts en france que la fin que la
somalie le soudan et le mali non ce jeu
tu veux pas non je continue à courir et
je sais qu'il est honnête il fera jamais
de politique
renard pas un fauteuil en armes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je préférerais mourir comme en rayon
laser bombe à neutrons ou gaz inodore
c'est bien un s'est tous bien la marque
ouais donc no n importe quoi je m'en
fous rayon laser ça fait un peu sonné on
adhère c'est comment ils meurent al
jarreau non tu me tues
[Applaudissements]
j'avais un perroquet chez toi tu lui
apprendrait ta ferme et le gaz tu as
pensé à la capote ou coco arrête là coco
tu as pensé à la capote da penser à la
capote fera un perroquet qui dirait ça
voilà est-ce que tu préfèrerais que tu
avais le choix elle trop cul-de-jatte ou
un puissant frein ou alors tu jettes
comme ça j'ai des collègues qui traînent
pas très bien donc tu préférerais qu'il
est impuissant non si c'est possible je
referais pas
oui bon choix
ces inconnus en 4e étage les synergies
et les inconnus déjà connu les boeufs o
la bonne balle de gilles les inconnus
ajouté mme lagarde que chez les mecs
super feignasses non mais t'as côté a
reconnu qui sait j'ai pas reconnu la
voix non non une femme ou un homme
c'est un homme un stand
soit l'un soit sur le minicar pris aux
yeux que je commanderai quatre signés du
sud dans la glace là un élément est par
ailleurs serait moi j'adore le champagne
c'est quand il est vraiment dire tout ce
que tu peux faire sur le but à montabon
soir bonsoir j'ai mon soir soir mais
hier soir thierry bonjour monsieur ferry
bondé manteau c'est là
façon m'a touché ouais d'attachant ah
ouais quand même
ah ouais
les filles aiment bien 13 pc vient
porter des menottes au cas où y'a pas de
radiateur alors michel comment ça se
passe alors mais ça se passe très bien
la promo 2 sexuels passait bien ils sont
dociles pour faire la voix moins dociles
je ne pense pas que ce soit le terme
adecco ont formulé sur casse couilles et
sans casque ou non mais c'est vrai que
il faut savoir faire des choix et on ne
peut pas forcément aller partout ouais
voilà un agenda très chargé
et voilà j'ai occupé d'intego l'un déjà
pas il en a vendu un million mais je me
suis occupé d'astérix café 15 millions
oui c'est vrai tu es donc
voilà l'un dans l'autre l'un dans
l'autre c'est bien c'est bon on est à la
vôtre merci thierry sur 7 pour moi la
troupe qui vendent bien le dvd moi je
trouve que mes traoré wendel
bon je considère qu elle c'est elle
ouais on était très mauvais vendeurs on
est coincé on n'est pas toujours bien
détendu quand tu clash en radio teva
chemin bien oui mais c'est sont maniés
avec mon physique et encore j'ai pas de
diluer ses kilos la traiterait bravo
pour ça nous emmène merci de non-lieu
pour vous c'est des trucs aujourd'hui
plus personne ne fait pas ce qu'on ne
peut plus les faire je t'avais c'est
vrai le paie le machin le truc tout ça
on a pu y aura de faire les gros mots à
la télé au monde ni moins en moins je
crois qu'on a pris morel le faire on m a
conclu henri le faire jégo douteux
censure à la télé beaucoup d'auto
censure et puis aussi les comics sont
plus dans le fin s'il ya des mecs l'eau
de javel tout ça mais ils font patelli
il fonde un grand spectacle quelque
chose comme ça mais il ya plus comique à
la tv le comique deux télés du comique
de teliris com saturday night la dame a
prestement dans les pieds eu un moment
où on faisait faye avait noué les a
connus et depuis plus rien lui ai alors
quelle émission vous avez fait alors
appartement on en parle on n'a pas fait
énormément non je ne faisais denisot
ouais
deux mises au toit c'est tout et puis on
va faire la radio rmc
alors si ces affaires un prime sur m6 ce
sera une émission c'est l'énergie bois
donc tu vois on est pas on se répand pas
non plus mon partout une serre en
faisant les beaux démission voilà ça
permet aussi de garder une certaine
qualité ne pas être partout c'est un peu
gonflant quand même que tu pas quand tu
vois les certains mais qui sont quand
même où tu zappes parti c'est sans arrêt
sur toutes les chaînes avec 2007 les
gones presque du produit donc c'est tout
le match mais qu'est ce qu'elle choisit
ce qu'il fallait rediffusé chantal a
beaucoup plus regardée que nous très
honnêtement
alors ben oui j'ai vu beaucoup de choses
déjà l'an dernier on avait commencé par
par des rochers pour l'intégrer l'un
donc là c'est la dernière que le gros
travail au lieu donc on avait d'un côté
les
cavaye père cartonné et de l'odc tous
les mois vu qu'ils étaient pas alina
donc quand les mecs qui demandaient des
sketches on leur envoyait toujours les
mêmes
c'était que c'était curieux d'ailleurs
parce que code quant à moi je trouve
dans l'intégrale 2 qui a déjà des
sketches chants qui m'amuse beaucoup
plus à la limite
barda connaît moins les a moins vu et
donc c'est comme du nouveau mât pour les
mêmes des petits des petits trucs perso
les petits films perso de bruno les
instants continue sur le point de partir
voir sa mère c'était un vendredi soir
certainement tous les week-ends il
allait voir sa mère donc il est en
pleine forme parce que là il sait qui va
descendre sur la côte c'est bon c'est
d'arriver donc nous notre t'occupes
regardez un peu les plannings qui se bat
lui s'en fout complètement il a son
avion à telle heure sont taxés il est
organisé et chaudes et il est en boucle
sur jean mérault puisqu'il vient de
mettre au point jean perron ce n'est pas
encore assez terrible alors on partage
et lapins ont partagé un appartement et
tout en écrivait eto'o et et bruno
étaient 24 heures sur 24 avec cette
chanson
des fois le matin je croisais film the
tudors dit jeannette j'étais surréaliste
parce que les jeux olympiques n'est pas
ils avaient détruit le riz cantonnais
pendant que j'entendais des choses pas
possible mais comment ça se passait
l'écriture c'était tous les matins vous
avez rendez vous les toutes les nuits de
phase iib la phase objectif nul on
écrivait tous les soirs chez les uns et
chez les autres
donc c'est des jantes beaucoup chez
chantal et bruno mes dons concédés censé
faire à manger sous cookies à manger et
on écrivait ensemble on commence à
écrire à 20h11 mais non on se mettait à
des facteurs les tablettes notamment ses
sacres à 23 heures d'arrêté vers 5-6
heures de 503 d'accord abbaoui d'accord
y avait la petite est donc le matin que
je
petit à petit que tu aimes bien et le
matin c'était l'école donc je savais
même plus comment je m'appelais tu vois
pas ce qu ont travaillé la nuit mais moi
j'en qu'est ce qui est dingue c'est
jennifer elle avait trois ans elle avait
une moto une petite moto à quatre roues
électriques t elle nous tourner autour
comme ça ça donne corps de série on
l'avait connu vraiment l'homme attend si
vous écriviez toute l'année vous
tourniez camp alors vraiment là où on
est et on tournait à jour la jeunesse
est existe un nul après quand on s'est
mis sur la quotidienne la résidence où
les batteurs et des semaines de tournage
tout le matin et après quand on faisait
le plus dur c'était de l'émission là on
écrivait ont tourné en écrivant internet
ont répété ces dissidences et quand tu
écris tu te met minable et un petit
salut tu vois les invités oui c'est vrai
les annabis avec le musicien les répète
là l'émission le soir en live et le
après chaque émission une fête qui nous
et nous coucher et les fait grave je
vais te dire on ne sait rien
le lendemain la redif altice et tolère
aussi 7h30 les été obligé de vous les
faire mais c'était pas à six rencontres
dont le contrat sera le pointe 2 et 1 tu
es seul à avoir eu ça c'est un truc que
je demanderai ont fait cette émission ça
va être le bagne de créteil
on a une fête à préchac je me souviens
de fête incroyable un deuxième contrat
c'était que coco bakony s'occupe des
invités c'était le troisième point du
contrat c'est n'oubliez pas de nous
payer
ricol gurls vous n en bricolage
parce que vous êtes nuls en bricolage
ouais et vous avez décidé de faire
cadeau à pas cadeau pas vraiment cadeau
nous savons combien je ne sais pas
bricoler et j'aime les belles filles
c'est un concept que j'ai réunis en une
seule qu'à cet effet casting commandes
j'imagine c'est pas en strips
soutien-gorge petite culotte ce qu'on
n'a pas des forcément des idées qui
passent pas les bouger la perceuse un
peu le temps
petit peu que je vais sur mes cinquante
donc ça commence à être des numéros
absurde de charme incroyable sûr que non
mais en fait non mais c'est vrai que
c'était c'est difficile de dire voilà
vous avez donc décollé du papier peint
ça dégage de la vapeur il fait très
chaud vous déshabiller pour être plus à
l'aise les hits quand même mettre les
filles à l'aise
l'antique oui mais mais je leur ai dit
que c'était extrêmement extrêmement s'il
était plus que et qu'aucun plus que
puisque même sexy quand même quelque
répit à la fin des scènes un peu
alors dans ces deux cas c'est fait à
jamel qui vous donne un coup de main
ouais ouais jamel il m'a demandé si
c'était une connerie
les bricoleurs si c'était vrai donc j'ai
dit que c'était un peu c'est vrai que
c'est un peu les deux c'est une connerie
mais que c'était c'était vrai donc il
m'a demandé ce que je peux faire une
bêtise de dans les ped l'ex-usine donc
j'ai dit bien sûr on va regarder djamel
magnéto serge s'il te plaît bonjour elle
s'appelle samantha précisé mena
elle va vous donner des conseils en
bricolage au corps est comme moi je suis
un érudit en bilingue je vais tous vous
traduire sans exception d'accord vous
pouvez me faire confiance
un ballet de guangzhou mène pour la
traduction
oui oui bizarre quand vous voulez
canyon où les plâtres de noces thème
derniers mois
alors pour aller à bordeaux c'est super
ça faut pas faire comme les autres qui
est fouillé qui passe par dampierre qui
passe par le triangle de rocquencourt
sans savoir où aller car la
domiciliation d'ici je me trompe la a6
là à 6 bis la fois prenez la santé cité
et en 2h24 sur bordeaux n'est ce pas il
a une vision bien sûr ça dépend d'où
vous partez de façon continue dans la
maison savons qu'un message est jamais
qu est ce qu on dit exactement
avait changé ses habits d'accord qu'il
avait un peu chaud c'est pour ça
d'accord tout chez abi canaris go oui
mais la vidéo disons le c'est un cadeau
de noël extraordinaire
moi je trouve à 99 francs franchement
c'est que 99 francs cassettes et dvd
ah ouais ça alors offrir ça noël non et
est-ce qu'après vous allez faire d'autre
qu'à cet endroit les kitchen dell qui
sont des ddd magnifique chippendales qui
vont donner des recettes de cuisine
je viens faire le casting paraître
cordialité linda parce que le casting
sera effectivement fait part des copines
pour avoir un peu leurs canons masculin
quoi voilà en fait au départ on devait
sortir les deux en même temps puis on
est passé de sous à huy canal + vidéo
n'a pas assez de ça non mais là personne
n'en voulait moi j'ai fait tout seul et
puis après j'ai proposé à canal que dit
oui mais ah oui c'est une idée vraiment
à vous au départ c'était pour perdre de
l'argent un petit peu de l'ambition
artistique on est une ambition
artistique une vrai qu'à cette pratique
bien alors votre premier film c'était là
on l'a dit tout à l'heure la cité de la
peur à prix du gaz on me dit qu'elle
était quand même le film qui vous a fait
connaître en tant qu' en tant qu'acteur
c'est vrai que celui de l'eczéma sous
les bras tellement vous aviez le trac
mais c'est exact c'est une très glamour
j'aime bien ça parce que j'avais une
bourse non ouais ouais bah oui je vous
retrouver dans l'intimité avec alain
chabat vous demandez lui de lever les
braves sylla de l'eczéma dessous les
bras ces quelques frayeurs il ya un
tournage en prévision voilà merci
thierry à ce mot là
c'était à l'achat mais le pire est à
venir
bon alors mais après il ya le cousin
métiers extraordinaires comme vraiment
vous a découvert comme acteur non parce
qu'au début on vous prenez un peu pour
un branleur foutu réalité je suis un
branleur ans mais n'en fait pas un bon
alors c'est une imposture dans super bon
comédien
oui vous pensez toujours que ça va
s'arrêter que les gens vont vous dire
avance apercevoir un jour que ces
messieurs il ya beaucoup de grands
acteurs qui pensent ça c'est pour ça que
je vous dis ça je pense toujours qu'un
jour là là le carrosse va redevenir une
citrouille vous pensez ça bien sûr non
mais oui c c on pense que ça serait
grave en plus ça va et d'être plus grave
mais quand le coussin j'étais très bien
merci il était bien dirigée par monsieur
corneau sur toi alors lui didier vous
avez réalisé dans le jeu vous remettre
votre petit alors la personne je crois
que vous avez fait vers votre premier
film c'est diane kurys et après celui
des ennuis avec elle au sujet de didier
germain qu'on en parle parce qu'on a vu
des tout le temps des petits bouts dans
les journaux où elle vous accuser de
plagiat en disant c'est une idée didier
que j'ai raconté un soir dans un dîner à
alain chabat et puis je l ai dit ça oui
non je peux dire que c'est ou alors
parce que comme ça ça sera clair
ouais non c'est un je crois qui a
développé aux états unis un sujet sur un
petit garçon qui transformait son frère
en chien un truc comme ça et après moi
je vais raconter mon truc j'ai me tiens
je me prépare ça et c'est tout ça
ensuite me revient cette histoire
qu'elle avait déjà développé en fait
avant avant que je lui parle de ça mais
je ne le savais pas et on me dit tiens
et développe elle développe un film avec
un mec qui se transforme en chien ou je
sais pas quoi
donc forcément je me prends les nerfs
parce que je lui avais raconté le truc
donc je l'appelle et les insultes enfin
je l'insultais juste les idées elles
n'appartiennent pas à ce qu'ils ont
entendu elles appartiennent ils ont
trouvé samedi mais non mais non mais non
finalement 1 est effectivement fin
elle avait raison vu qu'elle l'avait
vraiment développer voilà quelqu'un moi
je le savais pas donc après comme on
s'est embrouillé tous les deux le truc a
donné ce à quoi le truc à donner il l'a
plagié mon film américain avec un barman
déjà pour diabolo menthe
elle est coutumière du fait en fait on
n'a jamais eu de procès on sait juste
expliquer tous les deux il ya ni procès
ni plagiat quoi mais est ce que c'est
pour ça qu'il ya pas eu un didier lecerf
moment où vous deviez faire la version
américaine le didier est ce que c'est
pour ça qu'il ya pas eu la version
américaine
non non non non la version américaine
d'audi a toujours acheté par miramax qui
est une société de production indiqué
avec les frères weinstein et on a
travaillé dessus presque un an et demi
mais au bout d'un moment j'étais obligé
de leur dire j'avais j'avais une vie
quoi et que je pouvais pas attendre
assis sur une caisse que le truc se
fasse pas donc je suis rentré à ma
maison
vous étiez partis vivre là bas je
faisais des allers retours j'ai fait des
allers-retours est beaucoup entre paris
et new york ce qui est agréable c'est
est payé par la production était ravie
je vais manger des hot dogs et grossier
et tout ça est invaincu est devenue une
véritable usine à merde là bas c'est
monstrueux quand on fait ce qu'on fit
mais sinon c'était donc voilà donc ils
sont ils le font avec un autre metteur
en scène qui s'appelle stephen schwartz
qui avait fait chou thing fish qui
mettait en scène anglais très bien donc
maintenant bon courage à lui parce qu'il
sait pas des rapides quoi ouais ouais
alors ça quand même un mal pour un bien
parce que ça vous permet de faire la
suite d'astérix
c'est fait ça non non c j'ai commencé à
écrire donc j'en ai fait ça voilà ouais
ça risque d'être moins franchouillard
que j 10 séries z plus marrant non
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas j'ai envie
de faire ma version à moins sociaux non
non j'ai pas d'instructions j'ai je fais
cergy millions auraient créé avec
quelques astuces pour qua non pour
savoir si clavier valeur reprendre le
rôle moi je trouve qu'il n'est pas
crédible dans le rôle mais non pas
savoir si tu changes ça non je ne change
pas clavier je ne change pas de pardieu
fait astérix et cléopâtre il ya ces
adjani ou bouquets alors cessé c'est
très gênant parce que sais je sais pas
qui s'est vu que effectivement ses
sorties je suis effectivement côté dit
un peu rapidement
donc j'ai jamais rencontré adjani je
suis j'aime beaucoup gianni comme
comédienne mais non j'en suis à
l'écriture et je ne sais même pas qui va
faire faire payer ce bonus est pas une
bonne idée
il ya déjà belle c'est sûr ça qui fait
l'architecte de kyo pas non il n'y a
rien de aérienne sur un an mais n'en est
rien de sûr pour nous enfumer les
pétards en écrivant le script
c'est le meilleur moment c'est le
meilleur moment exactement
ouais quand on monte les marches ouais
un alcool et sacha guitry fait de
meilleur moment dans l'amour c'est
exactement ce parallèle à l'écriture
ouais je me cultive un joli nez linda
aussi
les jantes et c'est pour ces la truffe
du chien bon alors on va faire un tabac
une interview à l'envers tu sais ce que
c'est une interview l'envers oui si vous
me donner les réponses et bien je verrai
canada est une émission
[Musique]
voilà comme ça c'est surtout parce que
là c'est très bien qu'il est bien alors
je vous donne les réponses comme vous
l'avez dit fait clairement et puis vous
me donnez les questions alors la réponse
mettant de fabrice luchini qui est le
meilleur acteur français parce que vient
en même temps avec lui philippe sollers
[ __ ] alors je n'ai jamais lu un livre
de comment il s'appelle déjà
je suis totalement inculte il avait
ensuite parce qu'elle célèbre écrivain
français a une coupe de merde aussi
subsol elle marche bien donc je donne la
réponse
laurent baffie moi je dirais que c'est
un type formidable
déjà je parle à des six routes et
humains de la personne ouais puis après
tu peut broder là dessus qui est ce
mélange de 2,2 grâce d'humour de talent
de sex-appeal
j'ai pas linda hardy qui mériterait
d'avoir des plus grosses
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mettez votre machine à ce que je sais ce
que vous non par la suite un travail
d'approché vis là je suis marié j'ai des
enfants bien connu qui a la main droite
qui part un peu en couilles tu sais très
bien continuer c'est très bien guy bedos
qui ne manque pas de toupet bien qu'on
nous applaudit ont rallumé lumière et
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
dans son late
c'est un
fêter tout ça moi
[Musique]
yu
avec
voici alain chabat et gérard darmon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je nous arrêter
si nous arrêter merci bonjour demande de
vous arrêter doit aussi arrête toi
maintenant ça c'est filmé en eau alors
que tu rends donc alain chabat gérard
darmon
vous êtes ici pour la sortie du film
astérix mais en fait c'est pas besoin de
promotion ce film veut faire un carton
intégral c'est ça vous avez eu les
chiffres et où tous témoins tout est bon
mais salue donc céder
[Applaudissements]
comment je suis rassuré d'impôt est
rassuré franchement il n'y a pas de gros
succès mais quelle récompense mais sait
on s'attendait pas à autant de césar
pour les comédies en général y en a pas
et il y en a douze césars ou césar bus
césar huawei dont 11 pour d'armonk est
quand même incroyable dans le film c'est
ce qui explique ma venue ici et on
posthume en ai dit que ça va alors
astérix et obélix mission cléopâtre donc
c'est votre nouveau film avec vous
gérard darmon une pléiade de vedettes
alors je vais faire le pitch qui est
vachement simple en plus à faire
cléopâtre veut un palais en trois mois
vous vous êtes son architecte mais elle
veut pas de vous puisque vous trouve un
peu dépassée quand même un peu démodé
toute la sécu elle choisit jamel qui
évidemment pour réussir à faire ce
palais pour césar qu'est vous en trois
mois fait appel à astérix et obélix et
surtout à leur potion magique voilà
alors casting de rêve il ya monica
bellucci djamel alain chabat gérard
darmon edouard baer dieudonné claude
rich
chantal lauby les robin jean benguigui
isabelle nanty dominique besnehard
noémie lenoir magnifique magnifique ne
lui donnera comment qui ne s'use pas
j'ai suivi ce qu'est ce qu'il faut dire
dans le film astérix est très amoureux
de noémie lenoir et jeffrey qui la voit
on entend ou berthod totsi voilà alors
emma de caunes c'est énorme
claude berri est aussi est aussi gérard
depardieu et christian clavier
[Rires]
mais dites moi c'est pour ça qu'ils font
pas de promo l'un clavier et depardieu
parce qu'ils ont le sentiment d'avoir
été un petit peu mieux ça va mal non que
la vie a fait un peu de promo gérard
aussi la fais de la promo il nous a fait
une bonne petite journée d'interviews
avant l'autre jour tout va bien tout va
bien bien alors y'a pas joey starr qui
devait s'appeler nique la police
pourquoi parce que j'ai jugé que j'ai
coupé la scène l'écriture quoi pas
d'accord voilà y'a pas farrugia non
parce que farrugia devait jouer
cléopâtre ça c'est un truc
[Applaudissements]
passez pas vu les essais mais j'adore
monica bien sûr magnifique tv j'ai vu
les essais c'était autre chose c'était
enfin c'est alors tout le monde s'y est
mis votre pote bakri a écrit quelques
blagues
besson par exemple pas un philanthrope
besson mais il est venu pendant une
journée il est venu faire ça l'amusé où
elle devait tourner la caméra et de fer
caméra 3 sur le ton de voix là un jour
difficile en plus ouais y avait 2000
figurants qu'il y avait du monde il ya
les potes il ya la famille à carole
chabat il ya un maxi chabat il ya mon
mot de bouge le frère de jamel qui vont
des sphinx miniature tout à fait voilà
qui a été qui a été qu'est théorique
était à la régie lorsque j'ai bien quand
même c'est d'arriver à faire un film de
potes à 50 millions d'euros quoi c'est
ouais c'est sympathique jeudi pour les
gens c'est 350 millions de francs quand
même ouais ouais ouais et le prix de la
place reste le même le premier avait
fait 9 millions d'entrées vous en faire
15 à peu près non je sais pas c'était
quoi les chiffres millions de sur paris
sont à paris premier jour ce qui est
génial c'est que c'est un film de potes
à 50 millions d'euros
et puis que c'est aussi un arabe questar
dans un film de gaulois quoi entouré de
quelques jurons et entouré
un lien des juifs il ya des arabes il ya
des martiens et des maltais ya des
marocains avaient il ya plein de [ __ ]
dans le gène c'est comment on fait les
enfants tu sais toi seconde j'ai préparé
un truc pas
non tu vois le verre dans ton peuple
je fais heures de travail jusqu'à nouvel
ordre aux césar
ce ne sont pas les romains qui construit
les pyramides des trucs pointu là
je vais les construire les plus
magnifiques des palais et c'est toi
numérobis tu ne sers à l'architecte
l'architecte c'est à dire tu as trois
mois jour pour jour
top chrono ce chrome os est éminemment
partage avec combien de temps de retard
[Applaudissements]
la prendre un jour de plus
c'est clair il faudrait pouvoir la
chique l'esa je vous propose une bonne
nouvelle mais ce que ça t'a pas me
raconter souvent l'histoire de ce bruit
des panneaux gates la nationale 4 xx x *
eli lui et obélix et le pichet lfc
idéfix regarde des pajero matadi d'être
nouveau dit
l'embellie est tombé dans la marmite et
papoter
[Musique]
je n'ose pas
elle va faire un gros morceau qui rend
lourtau là le petit gaulois un nom de
héros du jeu jo mannix
[Musique]
30 janvier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est génial le ballet sur un feel-good
là c'est énorme
alors quand berri nous a proposé claude
berri vous a proposé vous ai fait un peu
votre chose saute au début mais comment
vous savez tout ça c'est bien parce que
je peux vous le faire à chaque question
mais c'est ce que je ferai à chaque fois
[Applaudissements]
à si haut
vous avez fait un peu la chochotte non
c'est vrai pourquoi j'étais en train
d'écrire un scénario que je pensais
banquette cabon et donc j'ai dit non je
suis en train d'écrire un truc donc non
j'ai pas envie de faire astérix de break
non plus la bande dessinée scambos truc
j'adore j'ai su tout de suite parce que
ce qu'il faut savoir quand même c'est
que la première ambition d'alain chabat
quand il vivait à massy après que ça les
amis aient quitté oran alain chabat le
petit pied noir exilé à rêver des toiles
disney oui monique alors c'est vrai nom
est branché bande dessinée depuis
toujours bien sûr je voulais être
successeur de walt disney quand j'étais
petit j'avais même mis ça sur profession
plus tard au cm1 un mot clé c'est pas ça
peut arriver parce que maintenant on vu
le succès que vous avez vous connaissez
quatre scènes berck tous ces mecs là je
tutoie les plus grands
ça peut arriver alors l'avantagent quand
même du premier astérix c'est comme ça
posait un peu les personnages ça a
permis quand même de voir qu'on pourrait
faire astérix au cinéma et vous vous
arriver là dessus après je dirais que
c'est un petit peu plus facile de
déconner au deuxième absolument c'est
pour faire plaisir à claude zidi quand
même non mais c'est vrai que mêmes je
veux dire depardieu clavier accepter des
rôles comme ça c'est quand même des des
rôles très très improbable jouer un
petit goût doit comme ça avec un
grenelle et moustache etc
alors bon pourquoi ça nous plaît parce
que là il ya des influences keane qui
nous plaisent de toute façon mel brooks
comme influences ya mike myers et les
monty python il ya zac ce qu'ils ont
fait y at il un pilote dans l'avion
guy les nuls ya les mules bien sûr il ya
jean yanne deux heures moins le quart
avant jésus christ cécile b 2000 il ya
des scènes mais c'est ça le dessert
genre
à lomé
[Musique]
c'est tout l'esprit du film c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas vu le film alors il ya des
gags somptueux que je vais pas raconter
bien entendu c'est pourri il ya pas mal
de références il ya des passages en
dessin animé qui sont très très bien
fait j'espère que c'est quand même une
histoire on regarde quand même un film
d'astérix et obélix
oui j'adore quand même par dessus tout
goscinny uderzo dans une meilleure phase
à mais c'est vrai que les enfants
verront un film d'astérix et obélix et
les vieux enfants comme nous verrons
nous voir pour la part j'ai vu une belle
merde
sortie avant la fin voilà il dit alors
tout ça a commencé alain chabat le jour
où vous avez réalisé qu'on a le droit
finalement et c'est vous qui le dites de
finir une bagarre dans le studio du film
qui tourne à côté un jour aperçu de sa
non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des trucs
qui m'ont mis des gifles comme le shérif
est en prison l'effectif de mel brooks
de ben ouais effectivement une bagarre
de saloon qui finit dans un autre studio
cinéma il ya des gros pollueurs du qui
danse avec avec des plume dans le cul 20
semaines le tournage quand même hein
nous est un vrai patron il paraît que
vous êtes viré c'est avec beaucoup de
bons toujours très perfectionniste
évidemment et beaucoup de calme ouais je
suis plus ça dépend des jours mais en
général je suis pas super nerveux mais
c'est la drogue beaucoup qui fait ça
emballant drogue
je suis là je le raconte quand même il
reste presque plus de potion magique
dans la petite fiole les darmon qui fait
ça s'il prend il fait
[Applaudissements]
les gens racontent pas d'autres y en a
plein alors oui non vous êtes tellement
calme et yuki vous appelez sur un
tournage casse-cou x tranquille x ah bon
vous ne savez pas si vous n'avez pas une
invention ça aussi c'est vrai ou c'est
fou là c'est vrai vous seriez pas non
c'est pas non j'aime casse-couilles x
tranquille x mais ouais mais ça me va
bien et jamel je vous ai fait tous les
soirs lui n'en faisait pas des fêtes
tous les soirs c'est une légende musée
des fêtes le en général le vendredi soir
ou le samedi soir 1 samedi soir au maroc
puisse contourner six jours sur sept
le samedi soir il y avait de toute façon
une teuf qui était organisé par où les
où les comédiens ou un comédien ou les
costumes ou les décors etc mais aussi
applaudi de toronto le mardi 13 mercredi
le jeudi à tous les jeudis et puis après
le week-end ont donné samedi dimanche
normal
moi j'ai raté tous aller moi j'allais à
celle du samedi soir bah oui vous êtes
bien marré a complètement gto thurman
qui ça a duré longtemps en plus sa durée
22 semaines bon bien alors sorti dans
950 salle c'est énorme
witt à paris non mais oui c'est une
grosse sortie c'est sûr c'est une très
très grosse sortie déjà vendu aux usa
j'ai par miramax voilà vers un mix
miramas et dans le reste du monde
bientôt non le reste du monde à acheter
comme le premier à marcher vraiment
partout en europe
the world il vous dira jamais mais c'est
vrai qu'il a abattu un travail colossal
on c'est un travail colossal de faire le
film il a il a bossé comme incroyable
façon il est il est né pour sa villa
dossier comme un coing la bonne réponse
amiable alors nous avec l'impression
toujours de faire un court métrage ouais
ça qui était incroyable alors vous en
faite un jour vous dînez avec votre ami
vincent lindon
oui et vincent vous dit tu sais que
chabat prépare un son astérix
vous n'aviez pas et je ne sais pas mais
qui trouve quoi ils fument j'étais dans
ma bulle
entre autres j'étais dans ma bulle où
elle était un peu j'étais un peu à une
époque j'ai ça se passait bah ça
n'allait pas trop bien ça arrive dans la
vie pourquoi te supplie si t'es quoi
alors je vais t'expliquer exactement
j'ai été sur scène ne dure pas toujours
non mais c'est un sentimental d'un bon
alors vous appeler alain chabab lui dit
alors non je dis pas alors je dis alors
je veux prendre un petit café avec toi
et me dit ok dati n'est pas de plaire
une sale période
ouais voilà je lui dit j'aimerais bien
faire partie de cette aventure
je sais pas quoi et et très franchement
je dis toujours entre la fin de ma
question et sa réponse il s'est passé
quoi j'ai pas une seconde nuit quoi même
pas il ad je ne sais pas dans quoi
ouais je suis d'accord voilà près de 2
de l'appeler parce qu'autant j'ai pas
aimé le film est autant j'ai trouvé
gérard formés et bien je trouve que
vraiment il crève l'écran et il a
appréhendé ce rôle de méchant d'une
façon fantastique et je trouve qu'il
réhabilite un peu le fille cette
débauche d'effets spéciaux c'est ce
délit de frikat ans c'est vrai qu'hier
ce magistrat en lumière dans le sud
c'est beaucoup du bourg de vous déguiser
comme ça et surtout vous avez inventé un
personnage qui est le premier reptile
humain oui dès la veille du tournage oui
c'est comme ça c'est dans l'est dans les
dents dans les affres de l'acteur qui va
qui veut pas les affres de l'acteur
c'est la richesse du maroc dit la vérité
aussi ça veut dire ça on a râlé d'accord
vous avez inventé ce truc d'une espèce
de rire sifflement comme ça oui je suis
tiens comment comment conquérir perso ce
6e mais qu'il est bon c'est un méchant
ça m'est cher vous [ __ ] kaki ski
qu'est-ce qui doit bien rire comment
éric en mairie j'ai trouvé ça se pose
est obligé de le faire je n'ai pas payé
c'est moins bien vous avez souffert
parce que ce tournage en plein désert
45° des x 55 degrés centigrades
et alors vous dites les bijoux chauffer
on a eu des fous rires dit de chaleur on
est des fous rires de chaleur
oui parce qu'on avait on avait la tête
pleine de recoins savait plus de cerveau
il devait faire à peu près 50 continuer
c'est fou 14h dans dr à ouarzazate en
plein mois de jeûne c'est quoi il
faisait 45 1 sous la tente de ces harkis
mais de la piège en voilà une équipe de
cinéma
les projets les flambeaux c'était
infernal et en plus les bouger les
bougies et les bijoux
[Rires]
voilà c'est tout c'est moche à bonnac
torti drogue c'est des conducteurs
derrière leurs essais pendant lés prises
je me brûler les doigts ont simplement
lisant au mont césar et la somme ont
colligé il avait mené déjà du bruit
alors après quand vous êtes rentré en
europe
en studio on vous a obligé à jouer la
scène avec jamel où vous marchez sur les
murs enfin comme dans les films de hong
kong quoi voilà sur les colonnes et tout
ça avec des vents du pendu à faire froid
là en revanche en hiver pas de chauffage
pas rendue a dit m les principaux champs
un quota chaud c'est ça qui est beau en
même temps c'est d'abord le travail dans
la maj l'industrie du rêve
le meilleur souvenir du tournage a lancé
quoi ça parle de cacher là on parle
non c'est le franchement c'est le
tournis super mauvais en anecdotes mais
c'est vrai que c'est le tournage c'est
le l'humeur générale
bon le meilleur souvenir c'est le
tournage le plus mauvais souvenir le
plus mauvais souvenir c'est le c'est pas
des mauvais souvenirs mais c'est vrai
que j'ai dirigé une ou deux scènes des
chiottes parce que je m'étais pris une
vraie bonne tourista et donc je suis
auto qui dans les chiottes assis sur le
moniteur de contrôle même pas le
moniteur de contrôle il ya des
assistants qui fait ces prêts tu veux
vérifier je fais non c'est bon ça l'est
[Musique]
alors là chabat et géant barmon ce film
va être un énorme succès vous ne m'en
voudrez pas de vous faire une interview
à nous porter la catastrophe
[Applaudissements]
alain chabat
le jour même de votre mariage vous avez
le coup de foudre pour une autre et
c'est réciproque
vous faites quoi
à
compliqué c'est compliqué je suis très
lâche je dis oui mon amour
ainsi ce faire
à
on n'est pas à l'abri d'une catastrophe
donc le jour du mariage coûte foot pour
une autre série 6-3 vous faites quoi
c'est pas ça vous est déjà arrivé
peut-être en plein jour merci de m'aider
je sais pas je pense que moi j'aime bien
les choses quand elles arrivent à moi je
sais pas si c'est une chose qui peut
être fait une médiatement je le fais
jouer après c'est vraiment un coup de
foudre dakar oui ils changent pas
alors vous êtes
en vacances avec toute votre famille
vous trouver seul avec votre belle mère
qui vous fait des avances
c'est d'après midi tout le monde est à
la mer vous êtes seul avec mamie givet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
amal moi c'est sans aucune hésitation
j'y vais au cinéma le vox est bon à
savoir
ouais bonne femme
dans ce cas là tous les chiffres du loto
mais vous avez oublié de valider le
bulletin à lui dit ça comment
moi je dis gagner du temps ouais c'est
ça qui est important ça c'est gagner du
temps les vignes et du qu'est ce que
vous faites
8 comment toi je lui dit donne moi le
le biais culturel que tu as à cocher
c'est toi qui n'as jamais bien tu
comprends pourquoi on ne s'est jamais
mariée c'est tout alors vous avez
draguer une nana super vraiment super ça
c'est vrai je suis témoin vous la
ramenez chez vous vous découvrez que
c'est un travesti vous réagissez comme
entamé pas arrivé mais
ok je la refais oui ça m'est arrivé
pas de problème il faut aimer les femmes
avec des groupes qui tourisme je suis
d'accord
les
est ce que votre père regarde l'émission
là bon alors voilà aussi des gros mots
et quand je me moque des faibles
voilà la raison il a raison à mort là
dessus la raison est un gros que les
tories c'est pas un gros mot c'est bon
c'est bon ça passe voilà c'est même un
nom égyptien gros qui tories donc ça
reste dans la mission cléopâtre c'est la
promo voilà ouais mon père comment il et
je suis toujours à l'école comment ça va
bien claude berri il est content de ton
travail
pierre lescure il trouve que tu
travailles bien
mais c'est mon fan numéro 000 quand même
c'est lui que j'ai vu à burger quiz
directement avec le père de farruggia
way avec le papa de farouches alors
attention interview catastrophe contrôle
de routine sur la route pendant que les
flics inspectent le véhicule votre pote
il était assis à côté de vous vous avoue
qu'il transporte 1 kg de cocaïne dans
son sac
vous l'avez pas dit bien sûr bien sûr
fait quoi
je le couvent mais après on partage
ça s'est pas passé comme ça je sais où
est ce que je fais est tombée d'un coup
il a fait un film derrière
de quoi c'est à dire quoi que j'ai pas
compris bien dans une bagnole oui
d'accord là je comprends le pote avec
qui vous êtes je suis aussi là au moment
où les flics arrivent
j'ai un kg de coke dans le sac oui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait faites quoi vous
lui dites à tête est un gros con va
essayer de s'en sortir mais ce vol on
essaie de 2,2 passes et ce en jette
après voilà donc
[Applaudissements]
sa vocation fait l'apologie pour les
arts est vraiment pour la balle ou bercy
votre fils vous annonce qu'il va se
marier 88 ça m'étonnerait à propos
toujours si tout l'esprit oui la jeune
fille s'appelle ben laden munichois
vas-y nicklas
[Applaudissements]
pour sauver la population d'une ville
dans cette brusque une liste pour sauver
la population d'une ville vous devez
faire sauter un train yes et votre femme
et vos enfants sont à bord alors
fait quoi désolé pour les villes et ça
va pas être possible
8 ma santé je suis désolé alain chabat
interview catastrophe
vous partez en vacances à l'île maurice
et rigolote et bien
je suis sûr
le 30 janvier
messieurs
ainsi alain chabat et jean paul rouve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
jean paul rault mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
laurent merci d'en
c'est très gentil
merci beaucoup m
et et et l'eau et leurs mamans
ouais
avant son ménage bonsoir lens il est
beau mais là bien sûr c'est austin
jabbar deux noms de faire des petits
quand même ses formes il a dit qu'il
avait réussit merveilleusement vous
espériez pas tant qu'entité mouche
pensais pas qu'il était comment petit à
petit les gens par ailleurs de gros et
plus gros il avait pas la moustache
c'est la maîtriser il avait déjà des
tendances avec pas les mêmes que
maintenant peut-être qui est aussi maman
tu t'es sorti de l'alcool en fait pas
maintenant parce que quelqu'un à part
les gens sont choqués quand vous allez
chercher à l'école quand on était petits
c'était bourré devant l'écossé gromit
souffert de sa part il faut plus en
parler parce que sa valeur ouais indique
si c'est vrai c'est sûr et il sert
toujours sur l'élastique
c'est lui a pas passé bah oui
à quel âge elle a commencé à la
rémy ans et demi oui un peu un peu
retardé tu sais plus tôt mais sérieux
qu'il avait le bouton rouge toujours oui
c'est tellement il était en veille déjà
comme un chien tu sais on dit prêt à
bondir
cheetah maire de laval rappelle que
oui mais également la maman de eric et
ramzy qu'on embrasse un passage vous dis
au revoir les prix à tout
et dans l'âge après l'émission bon
maintenant par les mamans
ck oui c'est bon
c'est un grand moment de télévision à
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau
mc
[Musique]
rigoler ma mère ouais je ne savais pas
qu'elle était goy et des dents bien
alors vous êtes ici pour la sortie d'un
des films les plus attendus de l'année
qui s'appelle voilà donc c'était un film
écrit par icc
ils ont fait exprès en fait pour ça
c'est fait pour ça morgan hacker servi à
acheter les billets ça sera bon jour
jouer une place pour donc un film qui
est écrit par les robins en
collaboration avec alain chabat joué par
les robins et alain chabat plus
depardieu rochefort valérie lemercier
dominique farrugia font des apparitions
pour le mérite aux légitimes par action
voilà et réalisé par alain chabat alors
le pitch je vais le faire je crois que
ce sera beaucoup plus simple
le pitch pas d'abord le fond c'est le
premier thriller préhistorique
nous sommes en pleine préhistoire moins
trente cinq mille ans avant jésus-christ
et pour la première fois un crime est
commis
c'est la première fois qu'un homme tue
un autre homme alors pourquoi tu es qui
a tué
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit le premier
thriller préhistorique ce la première
fois que va faire se pose est au niveau
de la forme c'est beaucoup moins
métaphysique mais c'est le premier
dessin animé dans les personnages sont
des vrais acteurs je crois qu'on peut le
dire
1 j'aime bien ouais c'est gentil mais si
c'est marina qu'a dit ça alors voilà
donc et la tribu des cheveux sales qui
veut voler le secret du shampoing à la
tribu des cheveux propres s elle le vaut
bien
voilà
et alors tout le monde s'appelle pierre
parce qu'on est à l'âge de pierre épiler
les animaux il demandé des poules
mouillées des canards mousse et puis il
ya des fermes où tu qu'on a ici derrière
voilà ça c'est une espèce de petite
poule rousse pour une foule mood c'est
une poule rousse laurent voilà ça c'est
ça c'est quoi ça leur coûte ça c'est
ailleurs comme c'est un cauchemar
ça c'est le lapin mucci le lapin mouthe
et puis il ya le foot
l'osmose voilà donc ça se passe quand on
goûte et des mammouths mais pas de mode
voilà c'est portnawak en fait c'est
c'est tout non s'est basé sur des faits
réels et il ya eu beaucoup de recherches
sur le sur le sujet notamment chasse et
en élaborant retrouver sa grande époque
vous avez retrouvé des documents blanc
bien sûr un puisqu'il a la couleur en
existerait à l'époque donc forcément les
enregistrements d'assez mauvaise qualité
mais qui nous entraîne permis de travail
et une base une base coiffe un devoir à
la véracité
voilà des bien sûr et beaucoup de drogue
[Rires]
auxquelles le personnage du vous appelez
le blond non mais vous m'appelez pierre
j'aime pas qu'on appelle le blond
permanent film lui santé un petit peu
différent des autres ah oui c'est
d'ailleurs ce un film sur la différence
je crois qu'il faut le dire tout de
suite voilà je suis seule blonde la
tribu et je vis je vis assez mal la
différence pour ça que je joue un
personnage un peu renfermé
c'est un peu un personnage et la clau de
sauter dans le film que j'avais quelque
chose quelque chose de sauter mais sans
romy schneider et michel piccoli mais
bon un drame rural
c'est un personnage assez épais au
milieu de tout ça un personnage un peu
tourmenté voilà un peu ton monte c'est
la première fois que je suis genre de
personnage suis très content mais c'est
vrai que c'est quelqu'un remarque
oui mais oui c'est vrai ça promet
ces valeureux n'a jamais ben voila si si
je l'espère marié fort j'ai vu mais j'ai
eu du mal à faire sur scène donc c'est
chabal et robin j'ai déjà dit trois fois
sortie nationale le 28 janvier 700
copies sûrement un cinéma près de chez
vous qu'il le joue parce que 700 copies
c'est énorme non oui oui c'est colossal
pas de vanne [ __ ] t'as de vannes ouais
100 copies par rapport à ces beaucoup
vous comptez faire quand même entré à la
à peu près avec mon film précédent a
fait 14 millions et demi d'entrées
devant se faire doubler
ouais donc je pense qu'on va faire à la
va faire ce qu'on va perdre ce sera plus
sûr on va faire plusieurs prises en
juillet vous comptez faire quand même
entrer vous allez me répondre d'abord
14,6 millions quand on perd quand même
très bas 14,6 millions là où maintenant
vous me dire si millions les faire
combien d'entrés vous les vrais chiffres
non je veux le chinois puis je prendrai
la meilleure prise en fonction des
entrées quand même non ouais dakar et ça
comme ça vous aurez raison vous aurez
toujours présent dans huit - six
millions à large
j'espère quand même entré 6 millions 6
millions mais on va refaire encore et si
jamais on croit migraine pour moi oui
quand même très peu dire 2 milliards
alors qu'orange a fait quand même entrés
et ont filmé deux milliards
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des milliards de milliards ce sont les
pertes de la production en anciens
francs en anciens francs
[Applaudissements]
en y versant 80000 en tête c'est faire
comme l entrée 180 me comme ma fille
alors est ce que vous êtes attaché de
presse sont là comme ça oui bien sûr je
crois qu olivier meriane meziane myriam
henggi hamel a très bien que myriam
qu'on va leur faire plaisir on va faire
les questions des dossiers de presse
comme ça ou pas il n'y aura pas de duras
pas de problème on est sûr que vous vous
rendrez le fil alors comment êtes vous
arrivé sur ce projet alain chabat c'est
amusant que vous me posiez cette
question
[Applaudissements]
comme comme comme producteur d'abord
dominique farrugia qui devait
initialement produire le film a été
appelé pour diriger canal+
bon ce poste allée lui prendre 120 % de
son temps il m'a donc contacté avec les
robins des bois pour savoir si je
voulais produire
c'est bien beau mais ça fait vraiment
chaud de cinéma le jeu mois qu'on est
vraiment bien fait car les gens sont pas
habitués à la spontanéité chez vous
avoir du plaisir à jouer même avec la
pression de votre double fonction alain
chabat vous réalisez que vous jouez sa
février mission de cinéma là c'est une
bonne question que personne n'a jamais
posé ça me fait plaisir
ardisson j'adore jouer j'adore réaliser
mais c'est vrai que les deux en même
temps n'était pas mon exercice favori
tout dire les jours où je faisais acteur
réalisateur
gt gt d'une humeur de d'ogm août
c'est très désagréable pour l'équipe
entre parenthèses qu'elle soit remerciée
pour sa patience mais ça m'a bien aidé
pour le rôle très bien
non mais qu il pas été plus simple de
tourner le film en studio alors on ya
pensé et puis finalement jean rochefort
accepté ouais
[Applaudissements]
quels souvenirs garderez-vous d'abord
choisi un sétois j'ai entendu alain au
début de la question alain chabat à
quels souvenirs garderez-vous de haut
il y en a beaucoup tout ce joyeux liés
au bonheur de travailler avec des gens
décidés à donner le meilleur
quant aux robins il travaille autant
qu'ils déconnent qu'ils se sont de très
gros bosseur et vous tue plus occupés à
la préparer vous et vous et vous et vous
attend d'après les figurants juste après
l'été durant le témoignage de figurants
ils font un devoir
jean paul raconte c'est pas ça jean paul
à la plage non plaît jean-paul à
l'érection c'est parfois font l'espagne
terrestres non jean pierre leblon
d'attributs machine star mais vous bien
et vous ont changé oui excusez moi aussi
excusez moi l'école jean paul pourquoi
dans tout processus verger l'envol
[Musique]
ces gros extrait de la bo du film alors
sur la bo yahia joey starr il ya ophélie
winter il ya fabuleux aussi à busta flex
il ya superbus ouais on l'aimé bien
c'est une fleur d'or jennifer et moi
aussi
et bien non il ya le making of en papier
alors ça c'est extraordinaire
donc il ya le scénario bhl pour ben
voilà ça c'est vraiment ton fils adore
la bible les jeux wii grave il a le ciel
couvert les répliques ya le scénario
original il ya les storyboards je vous
dessinez très bien monsieur chabat merci
tient vraiment et puis à des photos
aussi du tournage enfin cet extrait à
maman nul et puis elle et puis allez
peluche aussi évidemment les photos des
peluches voilà et maintenant interview
sans la bouche
[Musique]
jean-paul interviews sont la bouche
attention ne dit rien vous êtes dans une
soirée claude berri vous vous salue en
vous appelant jean pierre rives
vous êtes obligé de sourire parce que
c'est claude berri vous souriez comment
alain dans la même soirée nicolas
sarkozy arrive vous salue vous parle
vous félicite
un photographe arrive fait quelle tête
sur la photo jean-paul à ce moment là
une sublime gonzesses entre ne regarde
que vous vous êtes inaccessible fait
kate est inaccessible mais pas trop
inaccessible mais pas trop mais pas trop
inaccessible inaccessible je suis
excessivement au patro pas trop
voilà nicole kidman arrive dans cette
soirée où il ya claude berri déjà
inutile à sarkozy mais c'est sa phase i
et alors vous voient comme ça aille à
l'âne vous faites quoi vous le font
parce que c'est kidman exclusive à la
fidi qu'est ce qui fait que ce blaireau
jean-paul vous vous croisez quelqu'un de
visiblement important en fait vous
l'avez pas reconnu ces deux nouveaux
comics et alain delon fait quelle tête
jean paul jean pierre guérin le
producteur de julie lescaut vous raconte
vos débuts dans la série il vous propose
de revenir dans la série julie lescaut
un million de francs l'épisode pizza
pizza pizza millions de francs épisode
alors vous embarquez nicole kidman on
est lui dis moi je rencontre jean pierre
guérin julie les friteuses finale lyon
marque nicole kidman ses verrières en
même temps vous prenez votre voiture
vous allez prendre un dernier verre au
costes et là vous lui dites nicole
contrairement à ce que tout le monde
croit je ne suis pas d'oran je suis
américain kader aoun je t'emmerde
c'est pour commencer
oui moi quand je fais l'américain je
suis un peu classe fait comme ça que ma
jean-paul
vous quittez le soir évoque toujours
j'en avais marre d'être avec celles
trouvées sur marion game vous allez vous
allez au cost ouais et vous rencontrer
alain chabat une colle kidman qui
s'emprunte prendre un dernier verre il
fait l'américain vous vous asseyez vous
êtes là tous les trois ou quatre coups
et d'un seul coup
ophélie winter arrive chez bonjour ofili
mais bien comme chose dans les cheveux
je peux pas parler et là elle me demande
pourquoi
bah c'est un truc ardisson à dire
bonjour normalement
[Musique]
et en bas
le bar du genre
mercier de l'unique tard
alex freyre
josé
[Musique]
j'ai maintenant chantal lauby alain
chabat et dominic forget
[Musique]
bonsoir
allez me le plus ce soir
pour l'intégrer 2 alors les grues
[Musique]
bien grand pour un cumul vous aviez
choisi l'émission de marc olivier fogiel
par erreur et je sais pas et il avait
commencé
il avait commencé son interview par une
question que je vais à nouveau vous vous
posez c'est pas qu'on commence par leurs
excuses par une question que je vais à
nouveau vous poser cette année jean
marie bigard va faire le stade de france
ça vous brancherait vous de faire le
stade de france quel sens a répondu
justement j ai les réponses de l'époque
nazie
oui bah tu as dit sisi bien sûr si bien
sûr chantal a dit ah ouais ah ouais
l'époque la question vous avez tout à
tuer si si si quand même quand même
c'est à nouvelles réponses a quand même
pour chanter à la mène alors est ce que
le fait d'avoir fait l'integrilin il en
avoir vendu un million a joué dans le
fait de faire intégrer le 2 non ce qu'on
voulait c'était surtout faire un geste
auprès du public un geste de générosité
et leur donner du bonheur
d'accord mais c'est réussi
ce qui fait drôle un peu maintenant
c'est pour voir des bonnes émissions de
canal on est obligé d'acheter des dvd
donc c'est sûr c'est un peu plus
compliqué qu'avant mais on peut y
arriver quoi je m'inscris en faux
vous avez la nostalgie des années canal
chantal non non non non c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque si on prenait pas de drogue ont
été virés ce mois ci non non moi j'ai
tenu oui c'est vrai sinon voilà c'est
vrai qu'il est député à tous les étages
en tout cas au nom d'al veine le dire à
la tenue pas mieux pierre lescure se
promener à poil dans les couloirs c'est
vrai ça il était très à la retombée 1
c'est la fin d'une ère comme le bavoir
c'est la réplique du village natal
heures et d'autres nouveaux dvd
s'appelle intègre hull 2 pourquoi pas eu
un seul bus tul l'ubu où dominent
écuries du mais on y avait pensé mais
finalement
on sait d'où les bouchers non non non on
adore on avait fini la bouteille de vin
blanc
alors pour noël dans lequel il ya le
double dvd soit le double dvd soit le
coffret 4 dvd édition limitée collector
magnifique c'est quand même jusqu à
l'intérieur on a non seulement
l'intégrisme le livre des nuls plus tvn
595 plus toute histoire de la télévision
l'intégrale si les quinze jours nous
vous offrons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc on va d'abord regarder à quoi ça
ressemble vous allez essayer de regarder
tous les trois votre caméra et dire
ensemble celle là c'est lui avant le
choc face à l'allemagne et au search 1 à
2 3 vous dire tout de suite on l'a
décidé de s'asseoir et en même temps ce
soir beaucoup mieux connu six bonjour
vous me reconnaissez
bonjour me connaissez alors bonjour bon
après midi à tous voici le critt ou pas
elle qui grille mais comme on noie
monsieur qu'aujourd'hui
cent mille bonjours plus 60 mille roses
où ça nous fait 360 nouveaux ou en plus
c'est con mais tu n'es pas à ma place
johnatan que c'est la tienne toi tu
aimes et ses bras
c'est pour moi aussi
et là vous me reconnaissez
hélas alors tout de suite une petite
annonce de anne lise de sperme de
versailles
je cherche une moitié de brosses à dents
alors ne t'inquiète pas tout et tu as vu
les manches de pioche et nous cherchons
à les ranger sa boucle août et vient
choix considérable
pour la
ça va et là vous me reconnaissez non
hélas aujourd'hui je vous expliquer un
petit peu comment faire chier les
baleines
[ __ ] avec leurs trucs aux fibres géré
par les chiottes moi j'appelle ça tout
simplement de la saleté un peu grognon
aujourd'hui parce que je vais chez le
coiffeur
regardez le résultat on vire et nous
fait du tort c'est pas tout il faut que
j'achète un saucisson je me demande je
vais le mettre
bon alors qu'est ce que la zigounette de
ce monsieur tient elle fait 120 m de
long 1 iront bien il ya ya ya ya ya ya
non mais madame d'en faire passer les
bouchons et baba ou d'hélène cpai buzz
sap a décrié le bouton marrant je suis
juste avec le n'ont pas su la selo le
boulot de boot
non ça c'est les essuie glaces
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est comme la tv mais c'est pas pareil
dedans
il a bien fait oui c'est bien est-ce que
c'est intégrer le 2 peut faire office de
magnifiques cadeaux de noël
mais plus que magnifique super
magnifique super marchés comme l'asie
même le prix vous fera rire mais je
préfère le 2 ou 1 à huy bizarrement
j'aime les deux c'est pas mal ça c'est
parce que les gens sont paniqués ils ont
racheté leur enfin 13 une terrible mois
vous à démentir la wave ou à démentir je
sais pas faire moi savoir comment se
valent et nul ne sait plus à quoi
tendent et non pas par la santé le reste
mais si on perd c'est comme fred astaire
et ginger rogers quoi c'est quand vous
êtes obligés de vous retrouver mais on
fait ça pour l'argent
ça vous plaît de faire la promo saad et
moi j'aime pas du tout veut rien dire ce
mensonge
ouais moi ça me fait tout seul c'est ça
doit être un peu parfois ça dépend ouais
il est bien ce dvd l'intégrer le 2 c'est
une merde pour commenter sur votre
compte et mais si tu ne mets
il va aborder avec faut l'acheter pour
noël se tenait en bas non non non tas
d'autres trucs à acheter un achète le
dvd d'un fils à la halle à dire des
conneries comme ça on risque de vraiment
unique qui la promo joue lui même il ya
continuellement kiwi mais oui mais il
peut dire aussi te met à poil jeu mettra
pas pour bien ça y voilà jamais je me
met à poil moi mais ça n'aura pas coupé
j'adore laurent gerra
[Musique]
et maintenant c'est l'interview boîte
vocale
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie des
monty python si vous nous avez piqué des
sketches veuillez laisser votre message
après le bip sonore c'est à vous claque
moi j'ai raccroché on leur a rien volé à
l'averse de certains certains autres
vers des monty python qui ne nous ont
volé des trucs qu'on avait l'intention
de faire un trait aux dégâts longtemps
après bonjour vous êtes sur la
messagerie d'ophélie winter si vous êtes
prêts à faire la une de voici
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore c'est à vous salue ici d'homme ça
va bonjour vous êtes sur un messager
michel drucker merci beaucoup de
m'appeler vraiment merci
veuillez laisser votre message après le
bip sonore quand on va tâcher n allait
pas la famille bonjour vous êtes sur la
messagerie de bruno karachi absent pour
le moment mais laissez votre message
après le bip sonore pourquoi ouais
surtout qu'on sait c'est qu'à un moment
ou à un autre être revoir
ouais bonne nouvelle ouais ouais bonjour
vous êtes sûrs et messagerie de bertrand
méheut
si vous avez l'esprit canal veuillez
laisser un message après le bip sonore
c'est à vous salut c'est d'homme ça va
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
steven spielberg je sais ça calme
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore gentil ça va on le fera pas ce
film donc ça va façon t'as pas les
moyens donc laisse tomber tu feras pas
l'intégrer de 3,91 non bonjour vous êtes
sur les messageries de jean marie
messier si c'est pas pour de l'argent
veuillez laisser votre message après le
bip sonore 9 jean-marie toujours à moi
était de 18
qu'est ce que tu veux bonjour bien sur
la messagerie de nicole kidman si vous
êtes et dominique farrugia veuillez
laisser un message après le bip sonore
nicole je suis pris les semoirs système
ça suffit je rappellerai quand même
après bonjour vous êtes son ami s'agit
de ppda je suis chez mon coiffeur oui
alors veuillez laisser votre message
ça devrait être rapide tu peux me
rappeler groupe jazz ou de stéphane bern
gardien de l'esprit canal
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore garde le bien bonjour j'ai sur la
messagerie des nuls nous sommes en
tournée le vin chez ardisson le 25 chez
denisot le 26 chez cauet le 27 chez
shell 28 chez pascale clark le 22 à
venir complémentaires 34 veuillez
laisser votre message après le bip
sonore s'il vous plaît nous serons aussi
en signature à la fnac le tremplin pea
et le prendre 2 et est quelqu'un une
vanne win32 c'est pas possible
ah bah voilà
[Musique]
c'est comme
c'est ainsi
[Musique]
al assaba alain vous avez un autre dvd
vous un autre dvd c'est dj là aussi
c'est une édition collector limitée
donc est ce qu'il ya dedans alors il ya
vu making of qui est du storyboard voilà
des petits trucs qu il ya quelqu un
making of est ce que pourriez faire le
pitch de dj ouais c'est un c'est jean
pierre bacri qui est manager de l'équipe
de foot qui un jour on lui confie un
chien et un jour ce chien se transforme
en sommes voilà pourquoi j'ai envie de
dire parce que bas le foot m'intéresse
c'est une du site une fable de croire
c'est une fable sur la tolérance sur
l'amour sur cette fable est très ancré
dans la réalité sur évidemment il suffit
d'avoir un rayon bleu qui transforme en
chine et à ce moment là tout devient
possible
un rayon bleu ça l'explication là aussi
c'était du vin blanc alors je vais
regarder votre caméra et vous allez dire
magnéto ce serait pas l'air con tout
seul magnéto serge
il a validé jeudi sergent au sénat qui
donnait à la sois concentré sur le sens
qu'elle allait aux débats les audois bal
à papa la balle le journal nous sommes
chez nous et nous le facteur tous
empreints de magnéto serge
[Applaudissements]
comme ce cher la gagne à mme didier
[Musique]
auriez-vous secours de chiens là
maintenant il peut pas rester la trame
son humanisme
oui oui non mais c'est pas mon ami mais
grave pourquoi vous gratter
ce la seule explication sese seko
métriques baudis
c'est une réincarnation mais en super
série
bien c'est sûrement très clair pour toi
mais qu'est ce qui se passe avec ce
chien
[Musique]
c'est un didier c'est spécial et divers
mon chien tu crois comme origine c'est à
bras d'homme mais je vois pas pourquoi
didier est plus spécial que médor
c'est donc aujourd'hui que tout le monde
a décidé de me faire chier
[Musique]
oh
voilà il y les joueurs mais surtout
qu'on sait qu'on bagages à dorlisheim
gala le pain blanc ou bi oublier le par
ces battantes
c'est pas parce que tu pue ça me fait
des bonnes journées avec toi
on ne sent pas le cul sans pas le cul
des filles voilà
[Musique]
le polar méchant
didier didier en livraison de paniers
[Musique]
avec jean pierre bacri karim scellier
lionel abelanski chantal lauby dominique
farrugia josiane balasko voilà alors en
plus donc il ya le making of il ya
l'interview du dresseur et puis à vos
retrouvailles avec avec le chien avec
elliott le chien huit ans après ouais ça
s'est passé comment il avait un peu
vieilli pas moi et mais bon c'est des
années chien quoi une année chien c'est
sept ans qu'il a compris pourquoi
aujourd'hui on ne sent pas le que non tu
repas il ne veut pas retravailler avec
jean-pierre alors appât didier 2 way
rally veut pas non plus n'est pas
conscient j'accueille à shaba
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les magasins on n'est pas de la
tarte on marche encore à ces trucs là tu
veux des marchés moi je vais je crois
qu'ils ont alors bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
laurent commencé fort
bonsoir on ne présente plus maurice
barthélémy chez lequel maurice
barthélémy on ne présente plus
mais là
en bolivie d'un père diplomate devenu
menuisier en picardie maurice barthélémy
fumée un groupe est avant de faire la
bio membre des robins des bois
réalisateur de casablanca driver
l'histoire du plus mauvais boxeur de
tous les temps maurice barthélémy papa
de tess la fille de judith godrèche
voilà en revanche on connaît moins alain
chabat ça va pas trop intimidé un peu
quand même
il est moins connu la moins l'habitude
de faire de la télé le petit rat chabat
peut-être que les lecteurs de voici le
connaissent un peu quand même vous est
donné du mal pour être dans l'envoi si
après ça y est alain chabat fait la fédé
film l'histoire d'un chien qui devient
un homme un l'histoire d'un arabe qui
boit de la potion magique aussi tout à
fait un jeune maghrébin l'histoire
d'hommes préhistoriques qui commettent
un crime enfin vous avez déjà fait
quelques quelques trucs à la cbi
également réalisé une cassette de
bricolage avec des fils électriques de
prix comme ce choeur
et a fait partie d'un groupe j'ai fait
partie d'un groupe groupe de musique non
au nom de comics va pallier tous de quoi
tu veux parler pardon au temps pour moi
voilà c'est ici tous les deux pour un
film de maurice interprété par alain
chabat que c'est le papa qui sort le 1er
juin
et là je tiens à dire ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas vu un film
aussi bien parce que tu en as vu des
maires de certaines missions du génial
et un nom celui-là c'est un film
extraordinaire je suis sorti de là
j'étais complètement bouleversé
carrément en larmes quoi ça m'a vraiment
je crois que depuis le goût des autres
j'ai pas pleurer comme ça dès janvier au
6 août a été très très bon bien sûr
alors je vais pas raconter le pitch
parce que je veux pas dévoiler
l'histoire ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
c'est un road movie
il ya un break volvo avec un père et son
fils le fils à à 8 ans il roule alors on
sait pas très bien on sait pas très bien
où ils sont d'abord on ne sait pas très
bien d'où ils viennent
où ils vont tout ça on le saura à la fin
mais on comprend quand même que quelque
chose de grave a eu lieu et pendant tout
le film on s'interroge on est très en
fait très attentif à tout et on ne sait
pas très bien on comprend petit à petit
quoi exactement c'est à dire qu'en fait
j'ai essayé de placer des indices dans
le film de manière à ce que bon bah le
spectateur au fur et à mesure élabore sa
propre hypothèse et se disent bon qu'est
ce qui s'est passé entre deux et puis
voilà à un moment où on raconte ce qui
se passe mais là on m'a pas laissé
filmer au plus près en plus cessé c'est
comme ça c'est très authentique c'est
très pudique c'est très délicat
il n'y a pas deux il ya pas de pathos et
on sent effectivement qu'il ya une
lourdeur qui rôdent consent qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose et et on sait pas
quoi un truc grave bas un deuil ça on
peut le dire il ya un deuil ya eu un
décès
en fait il ya le père qui suit à ce
deuil à un temps en temps dans un petit
peu à saint fons utiliser et l'enfant
lui du coup à mûrir un peu plus vite et
les deux comme ça vont se chercher un
petit peu pendant le film et puis au
bout d'un moment il va y avoir une
bascule et puis il ya un personnage qui
arrivent et qui vient remettre les deux
à leur place alors là vous êtes d'un
naturel époustouflant dans ce film par
rapport aux autres chine où l'ipad est
toujours bon toujours bon non mais c'est
vrai c'est extraordinaire
vraiment merci ça m'a scotché vraiment
pouces bisou à les poser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est vrai mais risque encore alain est
parti tourner sims et qu'est ce que tu
veux à [ __ ] à tourner ce film là bas
avec maurice barthélémy dans le larzac
et en fait non je vois le résultat je
comprends quoi au départ alain m'a dit
quelques jours avant le tournage je sais
vraiment pas que trop comment aborder ce
personnage mais moi je lui ai dit sur
tout d'abord de rien du tout tu joue
exactement comme tu es de toute façon
j'ai écrit ce rôle pour toi ouais donc
ne te prend pas le chou vas-y comme ça
et toutes les réticences et tous les
doutes que tu peux avoir moi je vais les
utiliser dans le film et puis au montage
je vais faire ma propre sauce donc voilà
puis au puis finalement tournage s'est
bien passé très bien ouais j'avais six
semaines non mais c'est vrai que c'est
le film qui m'a raconté et les cinq
grandes familles le cinéma on en est on
est triste quand on quitte le maschino
qu'on le reverra plus jamais on est
triste ouais et pourtant on s'est
échangé les numéros de téléphone c'est
des conneries alors ce que vous allez
faire c'est regarder tous les deux votre
caméra et vous allez dire en même temps
magnéto serge tchador ce moment cinq ans
de magnéto laquelle brad un magnéto
serge voiture au modem c'est monsieur
madame
comme quoi comme gâteau 3g mais si vous
ramenez auprès des chamans x dégueulasse
les chamans et moi j'aime bien
non moi je suis ton père c'est ce que tu
aimes est ce que tu as peur tu sociale
oui oui oui oui à
ouais on devient comme
je penserai d'assumer mais toi tu en
penses quoi
c'est maman tient la touristique au
breuil comment ça va pour aller mieux
mais tu vas y avait claude j ça me fait
du bien quand vous êtes habile en
alsaciennes donc c'est pas du tout la
région parce que c'est la semaine de la
jeunesse les fameux bonbons à part
allume la télé est équipé d'un ssd mhc
quoi système de détection de mauvaise
haleine
elle sera lue morin quand il retrouvera
au soudan
j'ai pleuré que ton cul connaissent côté
jean mais triste
ça se passait quand elle est à pique
nique avec les amis et
je ne sais pas quoi dire
la disto rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que céline est ta photo pour que
ce sera ta faute
ce serait jamais jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà papa de maurice barthélémy avec
martin qu'on y est
6 et alain chabat et notre ami qu'est ce
sortie le 1er juin dans un cinéma
qu'elle chez nous il ya beaucoup de gaza
[Applaudissements]
mais ça l'est
il ya aussi
[Musique]
ans
outre le cas bravo maurice vraiment ça
dure 1h20 1h18 exactement on est dans la
caisse avec les deux on s'ennuie jamais
c'est un sacré pari en même temps oui
mais moi il ya un truc dont je suis
particulièrement fier c'est que les gens
quand ils ressortent du du film ils me
disent [ __ ] on n'a jamais vu chabat
comme ça et c'est vrai une vf c'est vrai
non mais c'est vrai il est il est
incroyable dans le film et le petit
garçon martin et est bouleversant il a
une mélancolie sur le visage et les
nostalgies naturel ce gosse c'est
extraordinaire oui ils n'étaient pas
payés ça aussi c'est vrai ça a aidé en
tout cas c'est dans les films qui font
le pari de l'intelligence à notre époque
et ça c'en est un voilà je n'ai rien vu
quatre ce qu'annonce était en vie il ya
un moment il ya un plan dans un
rétroviseur où il ya un qui a des
lunettes noires il ya une larme qui
coule comme ça sous les lunettes noires
c'est magique c'est magnifique à maurice
vraiment séduit qu'il faut féliciter
pour le coup il écrivait ça pendant le
pendant le tournage de ressasser ça
voulait réussi à écrire en même temps
casablanca driver re et papa oui donc
j'en ai un camouflet de temps il a eu
des velléités de réalisation non non pas
du tout avancé il a fait l'acteur la
totale et et les conseils qui me donnait
c'était plutôt des conseils de papa
finale mais de la paix n'est pas
dangereux de base écrit moi à l'époque
j'étais papa et dont lui me disait tiens
ça c'est peut-être un peut-être un peu
trop là dessus il a peut-être un peu
idéalisée le pape à la tête le falloir
le rendre un peu plus rugueux voilà il
ya beaucoup d'impro aussi parce que la
scène de l'alsacienne l'ensemble c'est
de l'impro c'est à dire la fille arrive
une fois vous êtes habillé en
alsaciennes c'est la semaine de l'alsace
après voilà puis vous vous dites aux
mômes 1 mais même les garçons
et puis martin c'est un petit gars qui
éternue c'est très rare les acteurs qui
éternue pleine prise il éternue
je garde à chaque fois je garde les
éternuements jeu pour sa trop mignon et
jetta du pollen
il est mal ce gosse alors vous disiez
c'était un ami ni depardieu se dire
qu'il est capable de rentrer dans mon
film tout de suite quoi ils se
concentrent instantanément ouais oui
c'est un vrai branleur entre les prises
ils n'arrêtent pas de faire chier tout
le monde
alain au bout d'un moment on lui disait
je vais te casser le nez lui a mis un
bourre-pif on peut les lire
oui mais bon des gens gentiment comme
comme un enfant tu vois un vrai pas mort
d'homme non ça va il va bien j'ai démis
l'épaule
voilà vous êtes papa maintenant alors
oui depuis un mois tu veux le garder
[Rires]
qu'on peut selon gilles pascal pas paru
le 6 sur l'os qu'on vérifie si vous êtes
des bon papa et qu'on fasse une
interwiew papa est-ce que vous avez déjà
regretter d'avoir eu un enfant
pardon j'ai regretté d'avoir eu un
enfant
non j'ai déjà demandé un test de
paternité parce que l'enfant avait l'air
un peu con
demander un test de paternité parce que
l'enfant avait l'air un peu vif vous
avez déjà fait un enfant pour faire
plaisir à la mer non non ah non
maintenant bien vous rappelez de toutes
les mères de vos enfants oui au la
plupart vous avez assisté à la naissance
dernièrement vous bien sûr vous avez
filmé ah non ah ouais j'ai assisté
j'étais derrière elle moi je voulais
devant elle elle m'a dit non tu dis que
c'est mieux vous avez déjà changer les
couches de vos enfants mais oui les
biberons vous les faites à elle allaite
mettais pas très très bien au début
ouais un peu le bordel que les couches
l'allaitement est ce que vous avez déjà
giflé un enfant régulièrement martin le
petit martin
exemple oui vous avez déjà oublié votre
enfant quelque part à part sur le toit
de ma voiture non vous proposez de la
drogue à vos enfants pour être sûr
qu'ils en prennent
je demande votre amour mais s'arrête
est-ce que vous avez déjà demandé à
votre enfant de rien dire à la mer à
propos de l'actrice dénudées qui étaient
là pour sa carrière en fait vous arriver
ça je vous ai déjà demandé à votre
enfant de rien dire à sa mère à propos
de ces deux jeunes actrices dénudées qui
venait juste des oui non oui tout à fait
non c'était un mais en plus ils auraient
pu en parler c'est le temps est vraiment
passionné ouais dieu quand la troisième
mais je serai toujours pas il va voir
d'abord étonné de même je n'aurai pas de
vanne mais je sais même pas qui va être
drôle banny est ce que vous avez eu à
demander votre enfant rien à propos de
ces deux jeunes actrices dénudées qui
voulait juste des conseils pour sa
carrière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez utilisé votre enfant pour
draguer des filles dans les jardins
publics
non je peux pas la maman est toujours
avec la petite fille vous ai déjà fait
travailler votre enfant à la non encore
six mois ça peut être faire un tapis de
2 mètres carrés cher mais j'ai perdu un
pognon les ordinateurs et des pompes
mais j'ai regardé les télétubbies sans
prendre de drogue alain oui et je me
suis fait chier je vous avais déjà fait
oh qu'il est mignon ouagadougou 12 au
bout du goût doux vous déjà promis à sa
mère que jamais au grand jamais vous
l'acquitterez ah ouais ouais
ah non mais ça c'est sûr c'est sûr elle
est la femme de ma vie oui un texto de
judith pour dire que ces barres et ça
vient de tomber
est ce que votre enfant vous a déjà
appelé monsieur tellement n'était pas
habitué à vous voir la maison
je salue l'équipe de chrétiens n'ont
toujours pas vous avez déjà caresser les
cheveux de votre enfant en pensant à
l'économie d'impôt que ça vous fait
faire mal
déjà jean vient pas qu'elle ait des
cheveux franchement je ne dirais pas
pris ça de son père c'est vrai qu'il ya
plus de cheveux que vos gardes mais
paraît que si le film marche et vous
laisser pousser les cheveux c'est vrai
je vais me payer une perruque en or à
vous avez collet bébé à bord à l'arrière
de votre porsche cayenne à l'ag juste le
bébé à bord ils nous avaient jamais
regretté ne pas avoir pris un chien
plutôt n'ont aucune ligne ou non mais
non je si je trouve de la vanne un
moment et vous l'intégrer
jusqu'à samedi s'est diffusée samedi
j'irai réponse valence demain vendredi
mais j'ai la réponse survient on
rappelle les gens et s'en foutent rien
et on tourne à vannes est ce que vous
avez peur que vos enfants vous ressemble
un jour mon nom mais apparemment les
gens disent qu'elle me ressemble je vais
vite sans les jolies sa soeur
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
chaque joueur doit vous donner 1000
euros des trésors vous devez trouver
catherine barma et l'embrassé sur la
bouche sur la bouche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
alors comment c'était des lèvres d'une
douceur avec catrice une grande
amoureuse sur charlotte bon soir là t'as
vu quelqu'un que tu connais c'est toi
comme ça tout le monde s'amuse à me
salua la à la cantona vous connaissez le
rituel de cette dernière émission
les invités sont chargés de nous poser
une question déjà éventé sont chargés à
moi je commençais à la je sais pas si on
vous l'a déjà posée thierry comment vous
savez tout ça
c'est tout con c'est parce que je
travaille voilà mais comment vous savez
tout ça parce que les gens qui
travaillent pour moi sont très bons
aussi
ouais d'accord
[Applaudissements]
bon
charlotte moi je veux bien savoir ce que
tu pense à toi
écoute je pense que j'ai pas encore fait
tout ce que j'avais à faire et que vous
n'avez pas fini d'entendre parler de
tiers du ca
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est vraiment
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
alors une question pour laurent baffie a
là j'ai une question d'intérêt général
et une question de zoologie qu'est ce
que vous préférez les a logés au logis
parce que vous avez une théorie sur le
fait que le homard est un vieillissant
non j'ai pas de théorie là-dessus mais
je crois qu'on a beaucoup à découvrir du
duo marc il y avait des traces écrites
quand on écrit par omar m'a tuer ça pose
une vraie question et je crois qu'on est
au début des connaissances sur le monde
[Musique]
bien laurent
ouais d'accord
pourtant qu'est ce qu'on va faire le
samedi soir qu'est ce que vous vous
allez faire le saut messieurs les gens
ils vont reprendre une vie normale ils
vont se désaccoutumer ils vont refaire
l'amour à leurs familles vont voilà quoi
ali vont ils vont regarder d'autres
chaînes ou pas est peut-être le meilleur
conseil à donner aux gens ce serait
d'éteindre la télé de faire autre chose
que de regarder la télé puisque
maintenant il y aura plus rien de bien
on vous met un super programme qui va
cartonner voilà les gens regardent
l'émission de laurent ruquier qui sera à
cet endroit dalle samedi soir
[Musique]
en revanche les cassettes pour cette
dernière émission j'ai retrouvé un
souvenir tu n'as jamais rangé une
cassette de thann
c'est un escroc total ont remporté une
empathie
à droite on va voir alain chabat dans
tout le monde en parle et tous ensemble
vous connaissez le principe à attention
c'est caen 2-3 alain charlot que l'on
prédit abadie magnéto serge mais ça
marche pas tu vois je sais que c'est
quelqu'un qui le dit pas ça ne peut pas
marcher ce rien là dessus c'est à dire
on est on l'enlève pour le groupe c'est
pas bien humainement ce coffret
contenant des mois à attention 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
chat
oui
[Applaudissements]
ouais
oui
[Musique]
mais quand même il ya
aulas
non
chantal goya
qu'est ce qui à l'en
on me dit qu'il faut tout refaire non
s'il ya une caméra qui sur alain chabat
si vous pouvez me feel like assez joffre
ça noël c'est à faire à ta famille parce
que bien sûr parfois tu déconne mais
parfois ça m'énerve accéléré dj
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme ça
ça
en fait j'ai deux chansons bon j'ai
celle là et puis aussi celle là
[Musique]
c'est le conte la télé quand même c'est
rigolo
oui c'est qu'on ait ces rigolos voilà et
voilà alors sérieusement vous êtes ici
tous les deux ce soir pour le nouveau
film de michel gondry
c'est pas de la science des rêves avec
vous il ya gael garcia bernal miu miu
emma de caunes
ça sort le 16 août michel gondry c'est
un réalisateur qui a commencé en faisant
des clips pour bjork pour daft punk et
isabelle giordano juge les clips de
michel gondry assez farfelue j'ai trouvé
ça charmant mais ce n'est pas tout je me
souviens assez faire face et farfelu
mais c'est un garçon assez farfelue eric
assez farfelu seulement voilà alors
c'est un mec a fait donc des clips
ensuite il a fait human nature et
eternal sunshine fin voilà il avait
toujours d'un autre trouve qu'il a un
univers très déjanté voilà alors le
pitch je fais le pitch avec plaisir bah
oui c'est un des derniers pitch
giordanno qui va le faire le pitch c'est
une histoire de stéphane interprété par
gael garcia bernal qui est timide qui
est inhibée dont la vie prend enfin un
sens quand il se laisse convaincre par
sa mère de retourner en france pays de
son enfant soit là mais literie déçu par
le boulot soit disant formidable qui
l'attend il bosse dans une entreprise de
calendrier et il compense par ses rêves
voilà et devant des caméras en carton il
s'invente une émission de télévision sur
le sur le rêve un peu comme nos bientôt
un point alors qu'un film prémonitoire
alors alain vous le héros vous
rencontrent dans l'entreprise de
calendrier vous devenez vous donner à
ses amis tous les 2es et vous charlotte
vous êtes la voisine dont le héros
tombent amoureux mais il finit par vous
faire peur quand même un de stéphane
roux la maman quand même
vous êtes des gosses quoi alors regardez
à quoi ça ressemble d'abord c'est assez
étonnant ce film c'est assez c'est
génial
vous connaissez le principe 1 2 3 une
histoire d'amour c'est une histoire de
rêves
non c'est plutôt une histoire de
calendrier c'est une histoire d'amour
oui un peu c'est vrai c'est un peu ça
aussi tu es amoureux stéphane la
rencontre stéphanie effet mme stefanick
les claques catch match face à stéphanie
c'est la voisine
stéphanie elle est belle voyez le pen
elle fait des choses avec ses mains
plein de choses avec ce schéma ce sens
avec ckoi je te couvre une dernière fois
mais si tu laves je te parle plus jamais
de ma vie sur la bouche avec la langue
rippel tu vois ce n'est pas une histoire
de sexe non c'est une histoire d'amour
comme ça va mal passé et comme ça on va
dans le futur
cette machine elle est objective ce
n'est qu'une machine
c'est une histoire de rêves n'ont cessé
un rêve qui raconte un rêve
l'udpci l'a61 il à ces épisodes
d'inversion réalité
[Musique]
en fait c'est plutôt une histoire de
calendrier qu'est ce que ça veut dire un
maquettiste de calendrier professionnel
c'est quoi exactement
le calendrier se compose de deux parties
le bas avec les mois et les filles tout
nu et c'est que c'est d'un ennui mortel
c'est une route avec un gros bruit sont
nous on s'occupe du haut la partie
gonflant c'est à dire le nom du crétin
qui vont envoyer ce calendrier supplie
de ringard à ses clients en fin d'année
ah non je pas d'accord un film de
skieurs moi je n'aime pas de tall kalakh
enfants non c'est plutôt une histoire de
rêves et à cheval et il ya des volcans
en fait c'est un film de michel 2006
maintenant
c'est un vrai film comme ça maintenant
c'est un beau film qui fait qu'on se
sent bien en sortons jamais à charlotte
vous avez trouvé la meilleure définition
du film pour moi vous dites gondry
raconte des trucs qui sont a priori pas
grave mais de manière très graves comme
des enfants ouais c'est vrai que ça nous
fait nous des réponses plus courte sur
le montage est bon sur chez g m'a saoulé
il faut que vous voyez en fait
bon on peut se tutoyer si tu veux non si
tu veux parler du film qui parle du film
sinon c'est pas grave oui mais j'ai
adoré le faire j'adorais faire et c'est
vrai que comme driss et quelqu'un très
original donc le film devient le film
est très original alors le bruit
novembre il ya un autre film vous êtes
ensemble une comédie romantique qui
s'appelle prête moi ta main d'eric
lartigau gdc faire le le pitch
l'histoire d'un gamin de luis que je
je joue qui est entouré de sa maman et
de ses cinq soeurs qui est donc très
très étoffé mais reconnaît est toutefois
tu as fait et il lui met une pression
elle lui met une pression terrible pour
qu'ils se marient et décide de en fait
de le faire rencontrer une fille voilà
je vais finir toutes les phrases mois il
décide de louer une fille une femme
enfin barème pour qu'ils les pauses
disons pour la présente plutôt à ses
parents voilà à sa famille alors en vue
d'un mariage
oui c'est qu'en fait voilà il se dit lui
n'en veut pas dire la fin
oui mais quand même jeune pour aller
chez voilà il se dit je vais la présente
à la famille ça va se passer très bien
elles vont elles vont l'adorer on va
annoncer notre mariage est en fait elle
viendra pas au mariage et je vais tomber
dans une profonde dépression et plus
personne ne me ferait chier ces
histoires de voyage c'est son plan qui
va pas du tout s'est passé quand même
sur scène j'ai vu le film c'est vraiment
très drôle ça s'appelle prête moi ta
main ça sort le 1er novembre
moi je les lui c'est très bien mais
c'est bien et comme vous serez vous
n'êtes pas là la rentrée si je peux
continuer sur ma promo de l'année parce
que j'aurais pu démissionner
nous sortons un dvd des nuls
c'est dommage c'était pratique aussi
pour ça cette émission objectif nul en
dvd voilà et puis vous avez autres j'ai
une panda à vendre accepté franchement
qui est encore en très bon état
vous êtes tout le temps ensemble à tous
les deux maintenant là le film de gondry
le film de lartigau je passe de titres
quelque chose ils vont au bout d'un
moment un bon on va regarder la bande
annonce non ah bon bah oui non alors en
fait je voulais je voulais vous la
montrer pour savoir comment elle était à
oui je sais pas si on la passe ou pas tu
qu'on la passe
j'aimerais bien que vous la regardiez
juste pour me dire si ça va ou si on
change d d'accord d'accord
attention 2 3 paris - je ne repasserai
des camions je vais te répondre dans ton
cul ce n'est plus à nous de nous occuper
de toi luis mâtinant c'est le travail
d'une femme de ta femme
j'ai trouvé le plan pour leurs affaires
ou une nana jeu labriffe présentation
elle adore et on décide de se marier
la trouille bleue galère vous me prenez
pour une [ __ ] en gros je propose de
faire ma femme contre rémunération ça
n'a rien à voir les [ __ ]
moi mais c'est consternant et pas si ça
vous intéresse pas juste dire non non
non
quine de 1400 watts
sept jours
une fois les 1400 vous allez où laure
pascal que lisa alors on pourra pas
reculer les heures les minutes se trouve
que j'ai une vie aussi je suis pas non
plus dispo 24 heures sur 24 par mettons
nous d'accord sur un nombre d'heures par
jour
pour lui ce même une journée de huit
heures normales avec pause déjeuner
quinze mille euros la semaine
quinze mille euros la semaine pour dix
rendez vous n'êtes pas famille et quatre
souris en foutez de ma gueule quoi
bon alors vous fait vingt mille c'est la
grande semaine du plan
a pas du tout semblant moins embêtant
pour les futurs mariés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai bien
non moi je vois tes 2007 non je ne dis
pas non c'est bien saison ils ont une
surprise d'accord mais les biens qu'est
ce qui te plaît tant chez charlotte par
rapport aux faits des winter se dire
c'est la dernière il a le droit je vais
avoir des vannes sur ophélie winter
charlotte à part qu'elle est bruyante et
parlent fort je lui trouve toutes les
qualités te fais un disque
oui c'est que j'ai trouvé sur internet
service s'appelle quoi 5h55 c'est ça
hein avec 1 et du monde c'est très
branchés comme lire isabelle giordano
pouvoir par le prisme de la belge en a
désormais désormais non il ya de jarvis
cocker knickel goodrich surface ça va
quoi c'est du beau monde
ouais
[Musique]
tout comme
justice
[Musique]
voilà charlotte gainsbourg en
exclusivité mondiale s'appelle chacun
ça sort le 28 août voilà j'ai vachement
bien tu vas faire quelle émission alors
pour en parler de ton album je sais pas
rires est secouée ça va oui j'ai pas
pensé talent est bien aussi une chose
que je veux dire c'est que le 30 juin
donc est la fête des loges
le bracelet wpt est assez gentil c'est
normal alain s'occupe d'une association
qui s'appelle les toiles enchantées très
discret là dessus l'idée c'est d'emmener
des films qui sont à la fiche dans les
hôpitaux où les enfants sont
hospitalisés à long terme et de passer
les films récents comme voilà où j'en
vois tous les films récents familiaux et
donc aux à la fête des loges les forains
donne pendant une journée
la recette à l'association il faut
acheter un petit bracelet coûte 15 euros
et qui donne droit à toutes les
attractions voilà tous les manèges
c'est bien
j'ai vu des reportages sur cette
association dont vous occuper des toiles
enchantées
quand les enfants sont à l'hosto malade
et qu'on leur apporte les films qui sont
sortis une semaine avant salle c'est
fabuleux
même la semaine de la semaine à la
sortie c'est vrai il voit le voilà au
cinéma c'est vrai quand le quand les
enfants peuvent pas se déplacer c'est au
cinéma de se déplacer donc bravo à la
main c'est super et donc alors elle
tellement discret qu'on va faire une p
review la vérité sur alain chabat
[Musique]
est ce que oui ou non vous avez pécho
paris s'il tonne la semaine dernière à
los angeles
non j'étais à tourcoing est ce que oui
ou non on finit winter vous a mis dans
son cv à la rubrique expérience
professionnelle non mais c'est une vraie
bonne vanne est ce que oui ou non vous
avez perdu 10 kilos non
[Rires]
est ce que oui ou non vous êtes toujours
faim qui fraîche challah oui je suis
funky frêche je suis je j'ai l'apparence
comme ça d'un garçon un petit peu un
petit peu gros un petit peu mais à
l'intérieur je suis un grand noir
extrêmement muscles et quelques c'est
très bien
est ce que oui ou non vous êtes heureux
- depuis que vous arrêter mais sinon oui
je sais j'en suis est ce que oui ou non
jacques devenu producteur de films à
hollywood
je suis j'essaye d'apporter la merguez à
hollywood en ce moment je travaille là
dessus
ce qui est intéressant est ce que vous
n'en depuis cinq ans on pouvait choper
toutes les actrices françaises que vous
voulez à la oui bien sûr est ce que oui
ou non dominique farrugia vous surnomme
le serpent est lunettes
oui mais
il m'énerve c'était mon sur dans le
serpent lunettes est ce que oui ou non
les nuls vont se reformer un jour
peut-être
en tout cas nous sortons un dvd objectif
à la rentrée est ce que oui ou non
chantal lauby a baisé avec un des nuls
non et c'est pas on a franchement on a
essayé vous voulez rien savoir
est ce que oui ou non on canal est avant
tout une aventure humaine merveilleuse
dans laquelle vous avez vécu les plus
belles années de votre vie et qui nous a
permis d'accomplir vos rêves les plus
fous
merci oui canal est avant tout une
aventure merveilleuse way dans laquelle
j'ai pu accomplir mes rêves les plus
fous je me souviens plus bien du milieu
de côté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rappelant que l'anagramme de alain
chabat donne habitat canal
ah ouais ouais j'ai trouvé ça en
cherchant range en d4
je vais ça fait classe mais est ce que
oui ou non vous avez retrouvé l'esprit
canal avec stéphane bern amor amor est
ce que oui ou non vous la péter un peu
depuis astérix
je me la suis toujours péter c'était par
an et demi après je la paie de plus en
plus est ce que oui ou non vous étiez un
danger pour le gouvernement
et c'est pour ça qu'on a essayé de
descendre le fil des robins peut rien
dire non est ce que oui ou non on
préfère le chien là maintenant
[Musique]
n'a que 3 des rythmes différents
bien sûr bien merci à la merci merci de
dire qu'elles sont toutes différentes
parce que défend nous soit une fois là
mais voilà c'est exactement ce qu'est ce
que c'est celle-là vous vos enfants vous
devez annoncer votre séparation avec
yvan attal histoire de donner des sujets
d'articles le magazine people à présent
une autre
moi je peux vous devez parler tout
doucement à ses fins la chine merci à
quoi vous devez dire allons toutefois qu
à alain chabat oui c'était carte papa
donne moi la troisième vous devez
écornée votre image de jeune fille
classée tendance en vous mettant
devenant et ça c'est fait
[Musique]
maintenant que je sais qu'elles sont
toutes différentes cartes et les vous
devez envoyer un texto à stephen kiesle
bert rue steven spielberg spielberg
spielberg spielberg vient à non mais
j'ai pas mon portable
sinon je l'aurais fait bien sûr j'ai eu
d'amour son numéro comprend une autre
non c'est tout les mains dès que la
corde
[Musique]
ça ça va me manquer tu vois ça ce
pouvoir que j'étudie d'arrêter marché
toi tu me crois il étudie à tavannes de
couper la sono dans des belges est et
celle toi et avec ça un seul os je vais
essayer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un coin
j'ai tiré ce que vous n'avez pas essayé
ça avec les invités ah oui oui thierry
ce que je pense c'est vraiment
intéressant
il ya tellement de même qu'ils ont roulé
avec lesquels répertoire et bien sûr mon
invité formidable
c'était formidable équipe vraiment
formés et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez
un pouce bleus